foreign
Donald Campbell please uh Mr Cameron
will you please take the
God that the evidence I shall give shall
be the truth the whole truth and nothing
but the truth
foreign
for thanking you for the assistance that
you have so far given to this inquiry
and for coming to give evidence today
and may I also ask you to keep your
voice up and speak into the microphones
so that the stenographer can hear you
for the transcript
is your full name David William Donald
Cameron yes
you were leader of the conservative
party and leader of the opposition from
2005 until 2010 when you became prime
minister of the United Kingdom leading a
coalition government with the liberal
Democrats with Nick Clegg as your Deputy
Prime Minister and George Osborne as
your Chancellor yes to put that in
context you became prime minister in the
wake of the 2008 Global financial crisis
and you
um
remained prime minister in 2015 when the
conservatives won the general election a
new formed a conservative government
in 2016 you stood down following the
European Union exit referendum result
now your evidence this morning is going
to fall under four topics first the
architecture in place to deal with
large-scale emergencies in 2010 and
changes implemented during your time in
office
two the state of pandemic preparedness
before and during your tenure
three your concerns Around the World
Health Organization
and four the impact of austerity on the
Health and Social care service and
underlying health inequalities
first of all please can we have on the
screen your witness statement which is
at
inq000177808 can you confirm Please Mr
Cameron that this is your witness
statement and it's made true to the best
of your knowledge and belief yeah yes it
is yes I can thank you and for the
record it is in fact signed at page 19
but that signature has got adapted my
lady so we don't need to go to that
thank you
um we can take that down please
so dealing first of all please Mr
Cameron with the architecture in place
to deal with large-scale emergencies in
2010 and changes implemented during your
time in office
when you became prime minister in 2010
you tell us in your witness statement
that in your opinion the existing
architecture to deal with large-scale
emergencies such as pandemics derived in
large part from the Civil contingencies
Act of 2004 and since 2008 had included
the national risk assessment and the
national risk register assessment so by
architecture you mean framework
including legislation yes yes
but before coming into Power your sense
whilst in opposition was that whilst the
national risk register was a welcome
Innovation the overall architecture for
dealing with civil contingencies such as
pandemics and the National Security
machine more widely could benefit in
your view from Improvement
in what ways did you think it should be
improved um well I commissioned Pauline
Neville Jones who had been head of the
joint intelligence committee to write a
report on National Security and foreign
policy in opposition and one of the
recommendations she made was to have a
sort of full-on National Security
Council to have a national security
advisor to have a national security
Secretariat and the point was to first
of all make sure that the whole
government looked at these
um risks second to make sure there was
sort of real ministerial oversight
because the National Security Council
will be chaired by the prime minister
um third to make sure that it was more
strategic thinking right across the
board about all the risks and also
making sure it was truly International
so you were looking at risks of
terrorism and climate change and space
weather and all sorts of things but also
things like um pandemics and why I
particularly thought this was important
was what I think the Civil contingencies
um Act and the previous government had
done a good job in this regard I knew
that
um Prime Ministers are always in danger
of being pulled into the short term
rather than the long term and having a
National Security Council that you chair
in a national security advisor and
having us part of that looking at the
danger of things like pandemics and and
it would make sure you did focus on
those long-term things as well so that
was the point of the reform and I I
think it worked I really I liked the way
the National Security Council and the
advisor worked and the the time the
Prime Minister spent on that stuff
because it had a good structure and you
implemented those recommendations
um as soon as you came into office
that's right I mean it was we were in
the middle of the Afghan conflict and I
thought for instance we would handle
that conflict better if we had a whole
government approach and if
the National Security Council
could address the challenges and you'd
have around the table all the relevant
people whether it was the defense
secretary the aid secretary uh the
Energy Secretary the Home Secretary and
the Prime Minister
um and it well I think it's so important
is
um well of course Prime Ministers are
very powerful because they're Prime
Ministers they don't have a department
in the same way that other ministers do
and having the National Security advisor
and the National Security Secretariat
working for you and bringing together
the whole of government to address these
challenges
um I thought got politicians involved at
the highest level on the right level to
make sure this was being looked at
properly so a National Security Council
as you've described supported by a
national security Secretariat and the
National Security advisor
that's right and the National Security
advisor had deputies one of whom was
mostly concerned with intelligence and
terrorism and security
um and the other more with with foreign
policy but specifically part of the
um
a job of the National Security advisor
together with the national risk register
and and and the National Security
Secretariat which look at all the
potential risks and um you know it's
important that we did make
um a pandemic a health pandemic a tier
one risk so it was about looking across
the risks and saying which are the most
likely which ones we need to prepare for
the most and as I say this this pressure
always to look at
the most pressing risk the the terrorism
risk or the most dangerous risk or the
most immediate risk you need to balance
that with making sure you're looking at
all the risks including ones that might
not occur next month or next year but
might occur at some stage and that's why
I think this this reform was was
important I'm not saying these things
weren't looked at before of course they
were but this embedded in the system
um Prime ministerial leadership and
political oversight and a whole
government approach thank you now the
future of the risk of a future pandemic
was as you've already made reference to
prioritized as a tier one risk and
remained as such did it not throughout
your time in office one of the highest
risks that the United Kingdom faced and
and although
um you tell us at paragraph 12 in your
report that that
um that it was a pandemic that was
prioritized as tier one risk in fact it
was more discreet than that it was an
influenza pandemic wasn't it
um that that's right I mean I
I think um
I was just maybe getting ahead of myself
but when you know when I look at all of
this and read all the papers and thought
so much about
you know what subsequently happened and
the the the the horrors of the covid
um pandemic and you know let me say the
massive sympathy I feel for all those
who've lost loved ones
and for the suffering people have felt
the importance of this inquiries work to
get to the bottom of
you know the decisions that were made
decisions that could have been made and
the preparations for the future
um this is the thing I keep coming back
to which is it the pandemic was a tier
one risk
pandemics were looked at but there was
this
um
the former Chief medical Officer Sally
Davis has said it was a group thing it
much more time was spent on pandemic flu
um and the dangers of pandemic flu
rather than on
um pandemic potential pandemics of other
um more respiratory diseases like covid
turned out to be and
you know I think this is
this is so important because so many
consequences follow from that
um and I've been sort of wrestling with
well why you know I think the
architecture was good National Security
Council National Security advisor the
risk register and also this new security
risk
um assessment which was perhaps a bit
more dynamic
um but that's what I keep coming back to
is
so much time we spent on a pandemic
influenza and that was seen as the
greatest danger and it we've had flus we
have very bad years for flu so it is a
big danger but why wasn't more time more
questions asked about
um what turned out to be the pandemic
that we faced and I I it's
it's very hard to answer why that's the
case and I'm sure this public inquiry is
going to spend a lot of time on that yes
it because during your time in office
there were several outbreaks of other
coronaviruses across the world where
this inquiry is heard about multiple
outbreaks of SARS and MERS both of which
were coronaviruses
um I'd like to put on screen please
um the following document
inq000149-116 which is a note of a
meeting of experts including Professor
Mark woolhouse at the University of
Edinburgh and also Dame Sally Davis and
could we go to page two please because
Under The Heading clear and present
danger if we can highlight the third
paragraph we can see it in fact Corona
viriday including the severe respiratory
infections SARS Covey and merscovy we
note that although there are not
currently any vaccines available against
human coronaviruses there are vaccines
for animal coronaviruses now this was a
note from a meeting in March of 2015
when you were still in office a meeting
chaired by the former Chief medical
officer Dame Sally Davis to whom you've
just made reference do you remember Mr
Cameron if this assessment of
coronaviruses as posing a clear and
present danger was brought to your
attention by the chief medical officer
in March of 2015. I'm afraid I don't
recall a specific conversation
um
but and it's difficult this because you
know you're trying to remember
you know conversations you had or didn't
have seven years ago and of course
before this inquiry I've read all of
this documentation
and
obviously in the documentation there is
and the government did look at
SARS and MERS
and particularly there's operation Alice
in 2016. which I'm sure we'll come to
but in terms of the specific
conversation I don't remember that
um I would certainly say that
my relationship with the chief medical
officer was very strong and we met quite
regularly and
because of the experience with ebola
which I'm sure would also come on to yes
I think this was a government and a
prime minister that was very concerned
about potential pandemics and about
dangerous pathogens and about things
like antimicrobial resistance and and
all the rest of it so we weren't
backward in thinking about it
um
but it still comes back to this issue
um why so much time spent on a flu
pandemic and not so much on these others
although having said that you know the
MERS
um exercise in 2016. that was looking at
her respiratory
condition yes sorry I'm I'm yeah not at
all well you've mentioned a boner there
Mr Cameron and indeed you were
alive to the dangers that that that that
disease or a similar disease with high
transmissibility and high mortality
rates posed and in the except for
interruptions I think the point about
ebola though it was not it's it's less
transmissible but it's it's highly
lethal and I think that
um so we've been looking at pandemic flu
we had a plan for pandemic flu we'd
obviously wrote about in the National
risk registers SARS and MERS Ebola comes
along which is not that transmissible
but highly deadly and So you you're you
know I think the question I keep going
back to is
why wasn't why weren't more questions
asked about something that was highly
transmissible indeed with massive levels
of asymptomatic transmission yes which
which was Lethal but at a lower level
than either MERS or Ebola and I don't
have an answer to that question but that
that's clearly
where the gap
was was so concerned with you about the
Ebola crisis that you created a new body
didn't you a threat's body the NSC thrc
which is a rather clunky initialism for
the National Security Council threats
hazards resilience and contingency
committee yes and that predated Ebola
but I may be well I I I forgive me I
think in your witness statement you tell
us that it was it was formulated partly
as a result of the Ebola crisis and in
addition to which you also formed a a
horizon scanning committee and both of
which
um were
run by Oliver lettwin
um and Oliver lettwin was as you say in
your witness statement in many ways your
resilience minister
um
why did you think it was necessary to
establish the the threats committee and
the Horizon scanning Department
um I thought the threats
um
has its resilience committee I think it
was set up before Ebola but I have to
check that the reason for that was
as I said a bit earlier
um clearly the National Security Council
will spend a lot of time on terrorism on
security on Afghanistan on Libya and
Syria
um and things like that and so I thought
it was important to make sure that the
National Security Secretariat
and the politicians in the government
spent time on hazards threats things
like pandemics and other such things
that were less immediate and current but
otherwise you spend all your time on the
other things so that's why thrc was set
up Oliver was an extremely capable
Minister and had worked in government
reform was in the cabinet office and sat
on the National Security Council so I
knew he'd do a great job at at chairing
that and and running there and then as
you say after Ebola
um he suggested and I think the letter
to me is in the bundles yes we're going
to come to that in fact can we put that
on screen now please inq double zero
double zero one seven four five one
now this is in fact the contingencies
um forward look because the the threats
committee as you explain in your
statement
um had a six-month
um forward look didn't it which was a
much shorter term to when compared to
the National risk register which was
five years and the National Security
risk assessment which had a 20-year
timeline and this is is one of the
updates which as um as as the man in
charge of of the threats committee he
would give to you can we look at page 22
please and paragraph 6.2 and then we'll
come on to the letter in a moment
now paragraph 6.2 we can see here
um an outbreak of a novel strain of an
infectious disease causing causing
serious illness excluding pandemics is
raised within this forward look and he
tells you here that the risk of an
emerging infection becoming prominent is
always present particularly at the
interface between animals and humans I.E
zoonotic infections globally there are
currently three main areas of concern
the ongoing cases of MERS Covey in the
Middle East and Eastern Asia the large
number of Avian and human cases of
influenza particularly in Egypt and the
epidemic of Ebola virus disease EVD in
West Africa
um now we we can take that down please
and can we go to the letter which you've
made mention of Mr Cameron which is at
inq00014650
this was a letter sent to you by Oliver
letwin the following year we can see
that it's dated the 22nd of March of
2016. and we can read through this
together it's titled Horizon scanning
for international health risks diseases
like Ebola and zika can constitute major
risks to our national security I have
therefore asked the Civil contingency
Secretariat to develop a new scanning
system for international health risks so
this is the Horizon scanning group the
results of this work have now been
agreed with all relevant departments and
have been endorsed by the chief medical
officer I'm confident that the new
system will enable ministers to spot
major emerging diseases across the world
understand the direct risks to the UK
British Nationals and broader UK
interests in affected countries and
receive expert advice on clear and
flexible UK responses and mitigation
Arrangements a monthly report will be
issued to the health secretary the
International Development secretary and
me this will outline key International
health risks departmental assessments of
the impacts and actions to mitigate the
risks I've asked the chief medical
officer to approve each monthly report
before it is presented and attached as
an illustrative example of the report
for your reference to avoid this
becoming just business as usual I
suggest rather than sending these
reports each month to the NSC thrc I
shall write whenever officials have
flagged a health risk of particular
concern and then he goes on to to talk
about the implementation in April
I think this is an example these bodies
which you set up
extending pandemic preparedness to a
whole government procedure that that
what this was doing was encouraging
working in a silo so that fewer people
rather than larger departments were
going to be involved oh no no not at all
I think this was a really excellent idea
of Oliver's and I think it came out of
um Ebola because we'll come onto the
World Health Organization I'm sure you
know I don't think there really was very
timely information coming out of the who
about ebola and this was Oliver saying
let's have our own Horizon scanning to
look across the globe for emerging
problems and the next one that comes
along of course is the zika virus and
this
The Horizon scanning unit spots that
quite early and then there are
conversations in government so now I
think this was saying we can make the
National Security architecture work even
better if we scan the horizons and look
for novel pathogens and problems coming
down the tracks and I think that was
Authority good thing I don't know what
happened to this organization after I
left
um whether it continued but I think this
was a really good idea and I think it I
don't think it was Silo it was in a silo
at all right well I'd like to ask you
some questions about placing Mr letwin
in charge you deal with this at
paragraph 21 of your witness statement
in which you say in terms of oversight
of our resilience planning I found that
civil servants were very good at
enumerating risks setting them out and
getting them in the right order however
to get follow-on action I tended to use
very strong ministers in the cabinet
office and you say that in addition to
Oliver let when you also had Francis
Maude who were both very senior and
experienced ministers driving change and
action on those front
it may be suggested by others to this
inquiry that rather than having a
minister in charge of resilience there
should be an independent assessor so
somebody independent of government
responsible for resilience who might be
an expert and be able to dedicate
himself or herself full-time to the role
and effectively be beyond the Civil
Service what's your view of that Mr
Cameron I don't think they're
Alternatives I think they should be
compliments
um as I said I had the National Security
advisor with his deputies
but the idea of having someone
equivalent to that who's in charge of
resilience and threats and harassments
in the Civil Service level I think is an
excellent idea and I think the
government themselves has suggested that
I personally would keep that in the
National
um Security Council architecture but
then you do need a minister to take
responsibility but for two reasons one
otherwise there's a danger that the
ministers around the cabinet table just
think well threats and Hazards the
resilience that's taking care of someone
but someone else somewhere else and a
civil servant and so they won't spend
time on it and the second is the reason
I give him my statement which is not in
any way to denigrate the incredible work
civil servants do but I think ministers
often come at these problems on a
committee asking the question right
here's the information what are we going
to do what are the actions we're going
to take what's the outcome of this
meeting what are we actually going to do
that's different and I find that maybe
we'll come on to COBRA chairing Cobra as
often as I did that I think is what the
prime minister or another politicians
bring is is yes here's all the
information here's what we need to
communicate it to all the right people
to make sure everyone is across it but
what's the action what are we going to
do and I think it would be a mistake to
park resilience at the official level
and not have
senior politicians including the prime
minister at the National Security
Council discussing it I mean for
instance when we did the national
security risk assessment that assessment
came to the National Security Council I
can't remember the date of the meeting
but I absolutely remember sitting around
the table debating with the Secretary of
State for home Affairs and
Foreign Affairs and defense and all the
rest of it which risks should be where
you know have we got this right and that
that by its very act you're getting
people who don't think every day about
pandemic preparedness and the importance
of pandemics and other things that can
can happen to focus on those things as
well as the terrorism yeah you've
explained why you chose Oliver letwood
and the qualities that he had to be
placed um in the shoes of effectively
the resilience Minister
um
of course
I've been already assessed as a tier one
threat that is pandemics
um so I'd just like to to look please at
Mr leckwin's witness statement it's at
inq000 107810
and can we go please to page two and
highlight
um the first part of of paragraph six
down to an including
um the
um the words much less well prepared
halfway down can we zoom in please and
highlight that
no no
thank you he says during this period
2011 to 2016 I was not directly involved
in planning for the government's
response to pandemic influenza in the UK
in retrospect it may seem surprising
that my resilience reviews did not cover
this issue given the fact that pandemic
influenza was ranked High both in terms
of impact and in terms of likelihood on
the national risk register the reason
the type the reason was that I was
informed by cabinet office officials
when I initiated the resilience review
process in 2012 that an unusually large
amount of attention had already been
focused on this particular threat
because of its position in the National
risk register that as a result the UK
was particularly well prepared to deal
with pandemic influenza that the
Department of Health Was preparing to
carry out a major exercise to test our
national capabilities in the face of
pandemic influenza and that my time
would therefore be better spent
examining other whole risk whole system
risks for which lined Apartments might
be much less well prepared and could we
go please to the next paragraph and
highlight paragraph seven please
reflecting on that
Mr let Wing goes on to say I now believe
however that it might have been helpful
if I had delved into the pandemic
influenza risk for myself
notwithstanding the amount of attention
being focused on this issue by the line
department and the consequently high
level of preparations for responding to
it this is not because I believe such a
review would have been likely to lead to
any significant improvements in our
preparedness for a pandemic flu itself
but rather because it might have led me
to question whether we were adequately
prepared to deal with the risks of forms
of respiratory disease other than
pandemic influenza
are you surprised Mr Cameron that Mr
letwin in the shoes of resilience
Minister did not
perform any tasks in relation to the
tier one risk of of pandemic influenza
um well I think he he explains it really
which is that
um this was a risk that he was told that
was already well covered because there
was already a pandemic
preparedness plan
um but I I must say I thought his
statement was incredibly clear and I
think his he's being very Frank here and
saying you know the more people who were
in there questioning
what sort of pandemics we might have the
better and I think his suggestion about
having a sort of red team to challenge
whatever architecture you build it's
only as good as the people within the
building and the decisions they make and
his idea of having sort of red team to
challenge the thinking
I think is an excellent one because as
Sally Davis has said there is always a
danger of group think and and perhaps
that's what was happening here is that
we were so focused or the system was so
focused on pandemic influenza because of
the well-known risks of it
um that the system had got itself into a
belief that that was the most likely
pandemic and that was the one that
needed to be prepared for and so I think
Oliver's statement is very powerful so
you don't think as resilience Minister
ignoring this risk he let you down I
don't think he was ignoring it I I don't
think he was ignoring it he was doing
the work on
other risks because this one already had
a plan some of the other things he was
looking at catastrophic failure of power
grids breakdown of the internet you know
some even quite
um the space weather and slightly more
wacky things had had almost no attention
he thought they needed to have that
attention so I never felt Oliver let me
down right I want to move on to the
second area of questioning now the state
of preparedness immediately before and
during your tenure
So within a couple of months of you
taking up residence in Downing Street
and Dame Deirdre Hein produced her
report on the government's response to
the 2009 swine flu pandemic which
included 28 recommendations just to to
remind ourselves about swine flu it hit
the world in 2009 it was a an influenza
virus a respiratory disease causing just
under half a million Global cases and 18
and a half thousand deaths worldwide
with a fatality rate of between 0.01 and
0.2 percent and causing sadly 457 deaths
in the United Kingdom you were aware of
this report we're not Mr Cameron
um yes I can't yes I can't remember the
exact circumstances of when I was told
about it but yes and obviously I've I've
read it subsequently thank you can we
put it up please on screen inq double
zero double zero three five zero eight
five
and we can go please to page 96
paragraph three 5.38
thank you the national framework was
designed to prepare the UK for a variety
of pandemic scenarios up to and
including a reasonable worst case in
which the clinical attack rate reached
50 percent and the case fatality rate
reached 2.5 percent in late April The
Limited information coming from Mexico
gave cause for considerable concern but
as the pandemic progressed it gradually
became clear that a scenario approaching
that scale was unlikely a number of
contributors to this review have noted
that it was difficult to switch from the
plan we had
predicated on a worst on a worse
pandemic than that which emerged to a
more proportionate response and can we
now go please to page 63 and highlight
paragraph 3.65
dealing with the worst case thank you
top of the page the worst case in the
planning framework is for 750 000
additional deaths given pressures on
resources ministers will need to
consider whether they wish to make any
additional investment required to cope
with the full worst case scenario I have
no recommendation to make on what the
correct figure might be for the worst
case scenario although in chapter 4 I
have recommended that the government
Chief Scientific Advisor convene a
working group to review the calculation
of planning scenarios however I do
believe that it would be unsatisfactory
if the national framework implied that
government and local responders were
prepared to cope with many more
thousands of deaths than they were in
fact equipped to handle
are you aware Mr Cameron we can take
that down please that these worst case
scenario figures
that a pandemic could affect 50 of the
population it could kill 2.5 percent of
the population and assuming a population
of around 65 million in 2015 that would
equate to infecting 32 and a half
thousand people and causing around 800
deaths those figures remained in place
and indeed formed the basis of the
United Kingdom influenza pandemic
preparedness strategy the following year
and remained in place until covert hit
they were never they were never amended
I I
if you ask me was I I mean in terms I
can't remember exactly what I was told
at the time
um you've seen the report now though
I've seen the report now yes
those Figures were never altered during
your time in office and and as far as
the inquiry is aware although there were
moves to update the 2011 strategy much
closer to the pandemic hitting in fact
and those matters were never dealt with
do you consider that that was a mistake
well I think it was a mistake not to
look at
um you know repeating myself like not to
look at not to look more at the range of
different types of pandemic
um my reaction to reading Hein was
um like many of the other reports it
doesn't mention the potential for
asymptomatic transmission
and so
you know when you when you think what
would be different if more time had been
spent on a
High infectious
asymptomatic pandemic
um different recommendations would have
been made about what was necessary to
prepare for that that's
what I think is is is is is is my focus
inter in terms of um focusing on a
pandemic other than influenza it's right
that the strategy in 2011 uh States as
follows plans for responding to a future
pandemic should therefore be flexible
and adaptable for a wide range of
scenarios so that was acknowledged but
but but nothing appears to have been
done no further papers were prepared or
or exercises and undertaken to to to say
how that the strategy should be adapted
no practical Solutions well there were
other exercises undertaken like Alice
which was
so so other it I don't think it's right
to say
um the government only looked at
pandemic flu it didn't look at other
things the risk registers and other
documents mentioned MERS and SARS and
other types of pandemics so I think that
wasn't a failing I think the fake thing
was to not to ask more questions about
asymptomatic transmission
High highly infectious what what turned
out to be the pandemic we had and I
think there are occasions where reading
these reports you you can see was there
was that adequate follow-up
um to to some of the work
um I spotted that in one or two places
well
I want to come back
please
um I don't know if you heard the opening
statements to this inquiry but Pete
Weatherby King's Council on behalf of
the covid-19 bereaved families for
justice UK began with with your words
and I'd like to display please
inq000146 treble five and this is the
press release from June of 2015
um when you were speaking ahead of the
G7 Summit in Germany on
um the the wake up to the threat from
disease outbreak can we go please to
page two
and we'll go straight to your words
please at the bottom of the page where
we can see that in this press release
um recorded uh is the following speaking
ahead of the G7 the Prime Minister David
Cameron said the recent Ebola outbreak
was a shocking reminder of the threat we
all face from a disease outbreak despite
the high number of deaths and
Devastation to the region we got on the
right side of it this time thanks to the
tireless efforts of local and
international health workers but the
reality is that we will face an outbreak
like Ebola again and that virus that
virus could be more aggressive and more
difficult to contain it is time to wake
up to the threat and I will be raising
this issue at the G7 as a world we must
be far better prepared with better
research more drug development and a
faster and more comprehensive approach
to how we fight these things when they
hit
and indeed your plan that you set out it
included a UK vaccines research and
development network with 20 million
pounds invested from the outset and also
what you described as a rapid reaction
unit ready to deploy to help countries
suffering and such
um devastating epidemics in the future
was your warning that Ebola was a
wake-up call based on your understanding
of of the effect that Ebola had had and
and a concern as to how the global
Community could improve for next time
yes I mean I I you know the reason I
chose to Rose that rise that raised that
at the G7 was I I had become really
concerned about this whole issue and
Ebola was you know one example of it and
it was through conversations with Dame
Sally Davis and others that I became
more and more interested in this you
know I thought we had taken
important steps at home and this was a
you know genuinely trying to put on the
table the UK vaccine Network and the
rapid reaction force that you you
mentioned say that these are going to be
our contributions as well as this
Horizon scanning unit so I thought we
were putting in place
good steps and it was important to say
to other countries
um we all need to do this because with
ebola specifically
um
there was this sense that
a the
who was quite slow to announce that it
was happening also quite slow to ask for
help and the the help that was given to
Sierra Leone
um to to guinea and to Liberia was very
much ad hockey I think I put it in my
statement it was in a meeting it was in
a NATO Summit I was sitting next to
Obama and he said look the world's being
too slow on this we'll help with Liberia
can you help with Sierra Leone can the
French help with Guinea and it was quite
an ad hoc response that led to this I
mean we spent half a billion pounds
um sending troops and nurses and all the
rest of it and I think they did a
magnificent job but it was quite ad hoc
and so it made me think that we needed
again the international architecture was
lacking and we needed to put it in place
and that's what this press release and
that announcement was about yes thank
you
and I'm going to now turn to two
exercises UK exercises and one of which
you've already made mention of exercise
Alice which took place in February of
2016.
um and the hypothetical scenario of this
exercise was an outbreak of the MERS
Coronavirus in March of 2016 having been
reported to the World Health
Organization and caused about 500 deaths
most cases having occurred in the
Kingdom of Saudi Arabia this was a
tabletop exercise as the inquiry has
already heard involving the Department
of Health as it then was the NHS and
public health England and it was
commissioned by the Department of Health
in response to concerns raised by Dame
Sally Davis about planning and
resilience in response to a major
outbreak of MERS in England the cabinet
office and it is described in the report
as having Observer status and so does
that mean that the cabinet office was
not actively involved but was there in
order to to observe I'm afraid I don't
know the answer to that question I mean
I think
these exercises are good and it's
important they take place I think Oliver
let one's evidence about they should
happen
with great regularity and at a senior
level I think is is absolutely right
because as I said earlier you want in
the end to have ministers asking
questions about right well what will we
actually do what needs to change what
needs to be put in place and you want
their attention to be focused on on this
yes
um well let's have a look please at the
recommendations of exercise Alice and
they are in document inq double zero
double zero five six two three nine
thank you and if we can go to page 16
please
here we are the the page of summary of
lessons and actions identified I'm just
going to read through a few of these at
number one the development of MERS Covey
special instructional video on PPE level
and use number four to develop a MERS
COV serology assay procedure that's
blood test searching for antibodies to
include a plan for a process to scale up
capacity at number seven
to produce an options plan using extant
evidence and cost benefits for
quarantine versus self-isolation for a
range of contact types including
symptomatic asymptomatic and high-risk
groups and just going back a little
further at the page to number five to
produce a briefing paper on the South
Korea outbreak with details on the cases
and response and consider the direct
application to the UK including Port of
Entry screening
now you may be aware that Professor
Heyman the esteemed epidemiologist gave
evidence to the inquiry last Thursday
and he told The Inquirer that he thought
that recommendation 5 was an extremely
good idea to learn from the experiences
of South Korea in terms of their
response to MERS and to see how those
matters could be possibly adapted to the
United Kingdom in the event of a similar
pandemic do you agree that that was a
useful and important recommendation yes
I do and I mean I think it's it's I mean
read through now Alice I I
um because ministers weren't involved
yes but you know there's there's a
sentence in in in in Alice which is
access to sufficient levels of PPE was
also considered and pandemic stockpiles
were suggested that that's a sentence in
Alice but it doesn't make it into the
recommendations so
I mean if you're asking were there you
know failures does it look like there
were failures to follow through from
this yes I think the answer to that is
is yes
thank you at the same time we can take
that down please there is another
exercise being planned exercise cygnus
now although this was not delivered by
public health England until you had left
office
um in fact it took place over two days
between the 18th and 20th of October of
2016. planning for this exercise began
in 2014 but was postponed due to the
Ebola response were you aware at the
time that exercise cygnus was being
planned Mr Cameron I'm afraid I I just
don't recall
um I haven't in the papers I haven't
seen anything sort of a note from an
official saying there's this exercise
going on I mean I've seen notes of me
saying to Jeremy Hunt let's do a note on
an exercise on Ebola yeah I do remember
that but I I don't remember that doesn't
mean I didn't get a note about it but I
haven't been able to find one and I
don't think you you have all right well
um we haven't no
um but this was an exercise designed to
assess the UK's preparation and response
to an influence a pandemic the inquiry
has heard about it already and no doubt
will continue so to do throughout the
course of these public hearings but it
involved 950 representatives from the
devolved administrations the Department
of Health 12 other government
departments NHS Wales NHS England Public
Health England and eight local
resilience forums and six prisons took
part in the exercise huge then in terms
of organization I'd like to look briefly
please at some of the recommendations
from this exercise whilst acknowledging
again that that you had left office by
the time this report was produced and
could we go please to page 30.
now we can see that here we have the
lesson that the table of lessons
identified I'm going to move through
these quite swiftly because the common
theme of the recommendations that I'm
going to highlight is capability and
capacity in Health and Social care so we
can see at kl4 an effective response to
pandemic influenza requires the
capability and capacity to Surge
resources into key areas which in some
areas is currently lacking l i 5 please
further down the page
further work is required
where have we gone now
further up the page please li5
thank you further work is required to
inform consideration of the issues
related to the possible use of
population-based triage during a
reasonable worst case influenza pandemic
Li 16 please
thank you
expectations of the mod's capacity to
assist during a worst case scenario
influenza pandemic should be considered
as part of a cross-government review of
pandemic planning Li 17 please
the process and timelines for providing
and best presenting data on which
responders will make strategic decisions
during an influenza pandemic it should
be clarified
if we can have li18 please a methodology
for assessing social care capacity and
surge capacity during a pandemic should
be developed this work should be
conducted with directors of adult social
services and with colleagues in the
devolved Administrations
and finally li20
Department of Health NHS England the ccs
and the voluntary sector and relevant
authorities in the devolved
Administration should work together to
propose a method for mapping the
capacity of and providing strategic
National direction to voluntary
resources during a pandemic given the
experience of exercise cygnus it is
recommended that this work draw on
expertise of non-health departments and
organizations at national and local
level
standing back for a moment Mr Cameron
and considering that these
recommendations were made in October of
2016 would you have expected the
government to have implemented the
lessons learned from exercise Sickness
by January of 2020
you would
I didn't really want to
comment on my successes
um but I mean you would you would hope
so I mean I I
I thought a lot about this because you
know having been back through all the
paperwork and everything I I haven't
found any moment when
I was asked or the treasurer was asked
to approve sort of surge capacity for
PPE supplies or anything like that I
think that's because there wasn't enough
attention on the sort of pandemic that
we ultimately experienced but I hadn't I
hadn't I don't recall any
recommendations like that but these are
as you say are quite clear
um and I I think that
um the treasury while I'm sure we're
going to come on to money was tight and
we made difficult decisions about public
spending when we did need to spend money
on important priorities when we had to
spend money on a bolo we did and we
would right well well before we come to
deal with
um austerity and the the effects of that
on health and public health I'd just
like to draw together the the lessons
that that we have just seen identified
in these exercises so in exercise Alice
um we saw recommendations of a need to
plan for scaling a testing capacity for
isolation and self-isolation options for
asymptomatic transition and issues with
the provision of PPE do you know whether
those matters were addressed during your
time in office well what I know is that
there were there was capacity for ice
isolation when we had the a boat right
break in Africa and obviously there were
some cases in the UK but you know I
would say that the the problem with
Alice was that it was a a MERS outbreak
with a very high degree of mortality 35
mortality but a very low caseload and so
again that wasn't anywhere close to the
sort of pandemic we then actually
experienced by the time you left office
do you accept Mr Cameron that there had
not been any planning and specifically
of the effects of a pandemic and by that
I mean this there had been no planning
for instance by the Department of
Education about the impact of school
closures had there well um
I don't know the answer to that
um somewhere in the bundle there's
mention of school closures I think is it
with respect to Signet
um but but certainly that it should be
looked at yes
the point is during my time in office
um the there were investigations into
serves into SARS and MERS and other
types of pandemic including Ebola but
there wasn't one into a highly
transmissible coronavirus style pandemic
like we had and so these questions
weren't asked but but even in relation
to an influenza pandemic which had as we
have already established been a tier one
risk during your whole time in office
and here we have exercise cygnus
reporting just after you've left office
saying that there should be
um plans and Research into the effect of
school closures
um in the in the event of a pandemic
that hadn't been done it was being
raised as a recommendation in cygnus on
your departure from office because that
planning hadn't been done had it well it
had been it was raised that that as far
as I can see that's the first time it
was raised yes after I'd left office yes
which meant means that that type of
planning was absent during your time in
office but I don't I haven't seen a
report while I was in office saying that
sort of planning should be done because
the pandemic preparedness plan which had
been worked up by the previous
government and then amended and improved
and enhanced during my time in office
there were lots of recommendations made
and all sorts of things about stockpiles
of Tamiflu and all the rest of it yes
but it didn't go into things like school
closures no have there been any planning
of the economic political and social
consequences of the imposition of
restrictions in the event of a pandemic
um well I the answer that is first of
all our whole economic strategy was
about safeguarding and strengthening the
economy and the nation's finances so we
could cope with whatever crisis hit us
next and I think that's incredibly
important because there's no resilience
without economic resilience without
Financial resilience without fiscal
resilience and so that was the
absolutely line one of our plan for
dealing with any unexpected
um crises
um also I think I'm writing saying that
in the National risk registers in 2014
and
subsequently there was quite a lot of
examination of how to to respond to
different
catastrophic economic problems that a a
these sorts of pandemics would bring
about there were National there was
National Business resilience planning
going through area by area looking at
what you might have to do but I think
all of those I mean a plan you know is
is only as good as the financial and
economic capacity of a country to
deliver it and that was the most
important thing of all you've told the
inquiry that that as soon as you came
into office in 2010 and you and you
um made um significant improvements to
the architecture of planning and
resilience that one of your major
um one of your one of your major
intentions was that that would lead to a
whole system level of preparedness do
you accept that you you failed in that
in that desire by the time you left
government in 2016 there wasn't a
wholesale preparation and resilience was
it yeah I I don't accept that because
we set up a much Superior architecture
for looking at risks for judging risks
and planning for risks and that's what
the national risk register the National
Security secretary at the National
Security Council did and I think there
was more attention including more
attention of senior politicians onto
those sorts of risks than there had been
previously but as I've said
the problem was that when pandemics were
looked at there was too much emphasis on
pandemic flu and when other pandemics
were looked at including Ebola including
Mars they tended to be
high fatality but low infection and you
know the regret you see it in in all of
electman's evidence you see it in in
George Osborne's evidence is more
questions weren't asked about the sort
of pandemic that we faced but I think
many other countries were in the same
boat of not knowing what was coming but
I would argue we did more than many to
try and scan the Horizon to try and plan
we did act on Ebola we did carry out
these exercises we did try to change
some of the international Dynamic about
these things and we planned and prepared
in accordance with that the evidence uh
of Mr Man and professor professor
Alexander that was received by the
inquiry last Thursday it included them
posing this question who is in charge of
keeping the country safe what is your
answer to that question but the prime
minister is always in charge of keeping
the country safe and under my reforms
the Prime Minister was much more
actively involved because he was
chairing the National Security Council
the National Security adviser was
appointed by him reported to him and in
my case I'd set up a specific
subcommittee on threats hazards and
resilience that looked exactly at this
area with a highly capable minister in
I'm sure there are further improvements
we can make and the government has
announced some which seemed to me
sensible with the Proviso that I made
but at the Pinnacle of it must be the
Prime Minister because from all my
experience of of chairing cobras whether
it was during
uh terrorist problems or Fukushima
nuclear disasters or Ebola or or
anything else
the system works extremely well but the
system works better when the prime
minister is in the chair asking
questions driving changes and making
sure decisions are made So my answer is
it's the Prime Minister thank you and
we've dealt with your concerns Around
the World Health Organization and how
you sought to to deal with those so I'm
now going to move on to the final area
of questioning the impact of austerity
on the Health and Social care service
and underlying health inequalities and
I'd like to display please paragraph 26
of George Osborne's witness statement
which we have at inq000187308
[Applause]
paragraph 26 please
next page thank you
reducing the deficit and placing debt as
a percentage of the GDP on a downward
path was also essential to rebuild
fiscal space to provide scope to respond
to Future economic shocks a responsible
approach to repairing the UK's public
finances following the financial crisis
was essential I have no doubt that
taking those steps to repair the UK's
public finances in the Years following
the financial crisis of
2008-2009 had a material and positive
effect on the UK's ability to respond to
the covid-19 pandemic the most urgent
task facing the UK economy as stated in
budget 2010 was therefore to implement
an accelerated plan to reduce the
deficit indeed there was cross-party
consensus on the need to reduce the
deficit following the financial crisis
and you've already made reference Mr
Cameron to the need for this to happen
and in your view and for the positive
effect that that had on the state of the
country's fine Nancy's going in to the
um
going into the covid-19
pandemic
I make it clear we can take that down
please that the purpose of the following
questions that I have for you is not to
explore whether that policy was right or
wrong that is no part of this inquiry to
descend into those political areas
but what we are interested in are the
impacts and consequences of that policy
in three areas please Health inequality
and societal resistance
the Health and Social Care Act of 2012
and
changed the landscape of Public Health
did it not because it transferred to
local authorities and public health
features and the involvement of
directors of Public Health so from that
time from 2012 and those areas of Public
Health were no longer funded through the
Department of Health in the way that
they had been before
um
Mr Osborne also says at paragraph 71 of
his witness statement we don't need to
to put this up that the department of
Health's budget from 2011 to 2012 until
2014 to 2015 was to increase in real
terms in each Financial Year and that
that growth occurred in circumstances
where all other departmental budgets
other than overseas aid were cut by an
average of 19 over the same period
he also goes on to say that in 2010 the
budget for public health was Ring fenced
but of course as we've just
um discussed that was only relevant to
to 2012 at which point in time Public
Health was no longer funded through the
Department of Health
do you accept Mr Cameron that the health
budget over the time of your government
were inadequate and led to a depletion
in its ability to provide an adequate
service
um I I don't accept that
um neither on a sort of Big Picture
level or on a small Picture level I mean
the big picture level I don't think you
can separate the decision and the
necessity of getting the budget deficit
down and having a a reasonable debt to
GDP ratio so you can cope with future
crises I don't think you can separate
that from
um the funding of the Health Service or
indeed anything else I mean if you lose
control of your debt and you lose
control of your deficit and you lose
control of your economy you end up
cutting the Health Service that's what
happened in Greece that's what happened
in countries that did lose control of
their finances I don't know you can
separate the two so we made the
important decision to say that the
Health Service was different its budget
would be protected and so there were
real terms increases every year and so
for instance there were 10 000 more
doctors working in the NHS at the end of
the time I was prime minister than they
were at the beginning
um would everyone like to spend even
more on the Health Service yes I mean I
you know making these difficult choices
about spending was was it wasn't a sort
of option that that was picked out of
thin air I believed and I still believe
it was absolutely essential to get the
British economy and British public
finances back to health so you can cope
with the future crisis the inquiry has
received witness statements from Jeremy
Hunt who was the Secretary of State for
health and then Health in Social care
from 2012 to 2018.
um were you aware that during the time
that that you were in power Mr Hunt
um labored considerable concerns about
the structural problems within a NHS
capacity and the workforce and funding
as he has set out in his witness I I've
read his witness statement I he was a
very capable Health secretary I worked
with him extremely closely of course he
was always
batting for the NHS and for
um for all the extra resources he could
get
these decisions were arrived at
collectively I agree with a lot of
what's in his witness statement you know
where he says there's more that could be
done for for instance for future
workforce planning but I will absolutely
defend the record of the government in
both getting control of the finances and
increasing funding for the health
service at the same time aren't these
concerns Mr Cameron that Jeremy Hunt
sets out structural problems with the
NHS and Workforce and capacity the real
issues which preparedness for a public
health emergency needs to address not
papers and guidelines and protocols but
action to remedy fundamental problems
well I think what's needed to prepare
for a pandemic is is first of all you've
got to have that overall economic
capacity as George Osborne puts in a
statement without our action you could
have had almost a trillion of extra debt
and you'd have as well as a coronavirus
crisis and a public health process you'd
have a financial and economic and and
fiscal crisis at the same time
um but I I think the the answer to your
question is that
um the best way
to prepare is to have a strong economy
and the next thing you need to do is
prepare for all of the relevant
pandemics that you might face and we've
already discussed
um where you know the system I think
didn't spend enough time on the sorts of
pandemic that we did end up facing do
you accept Mr Cameron that the
government was repeatedly warned about
growing pressures on the NHS firstly and
from the nuffield Trust annual statement
in 2015
um which detailed growing concerns that
demand was outstripping capacity and
quote the warning lights on Care Quality
now glow even more brightly and finally
in 2016 in the nuffield Trust annual
statement before you left office which
stated slowing Improvement in some areas
of quality combined with longer waiting
times and ongoing austerity suggests the
NHS is heading for serious problems it
seems likely that a system under such
immense pressure will be an enable at
some point in some services to provide
care to the standards that patients and
staff alike expect well of course there
were pressures on the NHS is there
pressures on many public services but at
the end of my time in office I think
public satisfaction with the National
Health Service was still extract
extremely high I think the king's fund
it might have been was ranked as one of
the most successful Health Systems in
the world we'd virtually abolished mixed
sex Wards we'd got Hospital infections
down we were carrying out 40 percent
more diagnostic tests every week there
were successes in the NHS as well as
pressures but there are you know there
are always pressures on these services
and our job was to try and sort out the
economy which we did so we could then
have bigger increases in health spending
which Then followed
in preparation for your evidence today
you were invited to consider the witness
statement of Professor Kevin Fenton who
is the president of the United Kingdom
faculty of Public Health which is a
Professional Standards body for Public
Health Specialists and practitioners
with over 4 000 members
um you will know then that um according
to Professor Fenton Health protection
teams saw successive reductions in
funding and capacity over the
pre-pandemic years and a lack of
investment in Regional emergency
preparedness response and resilience
teams and the summary of His evidence as
provided to the inquiry so far in
written form is that there was no ring
fencing of funding to local government
for health protection that Health
protection teams had their funding
reduced and their capacity reduced and
that ultimately this resulted in a lack
of capacity for pandemic preparedness
what's your response to that please well
I read the Fenton report as the other
reports I I thought
um
yeah I mean I don't want to be too
critical but throughout all of them I
thought there was very little acceptance
that it is possible to reform public
sector organizations uh sometimes to
merge them and get rid of duplicating
bureaucracies and overheads and get more
output for the same amount of money I
thought in in kershel in Marmot in in
Fenton
um there was just this assumption that
you only ever measure inputs rather than
measuring outputs so for instance I
would say the creation of Public Health
England where a lot of it was merging
together a lot of other bodies increased
the focus on public health meant money
was spent more wisely and I would argue
also that the Health and Social Care Act
by putting Public Health into local
authorities that was the right place for
it local authorities are responsible for
housing and for education and for
licensing and so making them responsible
for public health is is very logical and
even I I think most of the experts
coming to your inquiry I don't think
people are arguing to turn the clock
back and put it into the Health Service
so I think these were good reforms and
yes we faced very difficult Financial
circumstances but where we could we
tried to encourage the spending of money
more wisely and sometimes the merging of
public bodies was a sensible thing but
they don't seem to give that much
Credence well you've mentioned the
evidence of Professor Sir Michael Marmot
and Professor Claire bambra and you've
clearly read their report and you will
know that they gave evidence to this
inquiry on Friday
do you accept their evidence Mr Cameron
that Health inequalities increased
during your time in office
well I
I mean I've read their reports yes um
except that after
2011 in lots of countries in the world
uh life expectancy continued to improve
but didn't continue to improve so
quickly
um now their conclusion is to Look a Lot
at
um austerity and and what have you uh
I'm not sure the figures fact that out
we had some very difficult Winters with
very bad flu pandemics I think that had
an effect we had the effect that the
improvements in cardiovascular disease
the big benefits had already come
through before that period and that was
tailing off and then you've got the
evidence from other countries I mean
Greece and Spain
had far more austerity brutal Cuts in
yet their life expectancy went up so I
don't think it it follows and I found
you know I mean there's one sentence in
in Bamber and Marmot that just baldly
says you know child poverty increase
well actually the number of children
living in absolute poverty went down the
number of people living in absolute
poverty went down the number of
pensioners living in absolute poverty
went down very considerably so I I
so you don't just you don't agree with
that well they've got lots of important
evidence and I've looked at it very
carefully and I will think about it very
carefully but I did find the the I found
that they had left to a certain set of
um conclusions quite quickly not all of
which was backed up by the evidence and
they don't mention
the evidence that I've just mentioned
which I think is quite important
um I mean added to the fact that I agree
with Professor Bamba that social and
economic conditions have a big bearing
on health inequalities and so therefore
the fact that there were 2.6 million
more people in work there were over half
a million fewer children in households
where no one worked that these are there
were obviously a big dent in pensioner
poverty because of the triple lock and
the increase in the pension
um these are positives as well which
they don't seem to get mentioned in the
same way so I had my problems with them
but I'm sure the inquiry can look at
look at all the evidence and come to its
conclusions do you accept that cuts to
Public Health budgets tended to be
largest in the most deprived areas and
that as a result local authorities
working with the most vulnerable
populations face the biggest challenges
in carrying out their Public Health
functions no I I don't necessarily
accept that the way um the local
Authority spending decisions were made
was to try and make sure sure that the
reductions in spending power in each
local Authority were broadly equivalent
and obviously when you're looking at
spending power you've got to look at the
grants from central government to local
government the the business rate revenue
and the council tax revenue and so for
instance I mean I checked this last
night the 2015 settlement was for a a no
no council should lose more than six
percent of its spending power
um and so that does affect different
councils in different way in terms of
their Grant but it affects them in a
more similar way when it comes to
spending power and it's obviously the
spending power that a council has that
matters and I think that's a better way
of measuring it right but where you were
aware whilst in government of evidence
that people from lower social economic
groups and minority ethnic groups would
be more likely to be affected by whole
system catastrophic shocks I I think it
was well known and I knew that when you
have health pandemics of any sort you
get differential effects on different
parts of the population I think it's
coronavirus turned out the biggest
um
uh
category that's the wrong word the
biggest impact was obviously on older
people but many of our policies were
directed towards lifting people out of
poverty the the more jobs
um the the first national living wage
the big increase in the minimum wage
taking four million people out of paying
income tax all of these things the
reformed Universal Credit and the reform
of welfare and the whole effort of
getting people out of welfare and into
work all of these things have an
economic and social benefit but also
have a health benefit too
the inquiry saw last Friday that
pre-existing Health inequalities only
featured minimally in the UK pandemic
planning in fact they were barely
mentioned at all do you accept that this
was a significant emission I think all
plans can be improved and updated and
I've read the evidence about that and
I'm sure future plans will but
if you're asking was it you know was it
did you understand
um did your government understand the
importance of trying to lift people out
of poverty and into work and into
um Prosperity yes absolutely that's what
the whole plan was about and going back
to this economic thing because it is
important you know over the period of my
government in the G7 after America we
had fastest growth of GDP and fastest
growth of GDP per head so this is
important because ultimately your health
system is only as strong as your economy
because one pays for the other do you
agree that different political decisions
will have to be made in the future if a
strong public health system is to be
nurtured to withstand another pandemic
I think different decisions well I think
we need to improve the way we look at
pandemics and the way we plan our
resilience because while as I've said
you know the architecture was there the
structure was better The involvement of
ministers was better
the dialogue of innocence of the civil
servants was good there is this Gap that
I keep coming back to which is how do we
make sure that you're not subject to
group things that you don't plan for one
type of pandemic because it's very
current it's very risky it's very
dangerous you need to have teams going
in to question uh the assumptions and I
mean the biggest one was this issue
about asymptomatic transmission I kept
looking through all these documents
looking for what about
a pandemic with wide-scale asymptomatic
transmission and if if that question in
art and a lot of things would follow
from that you know
in Jeremy Hunt's evidence
hospitals in Hong Kong had to have three
months of PPE supplies I was never asked
can we have funding for three months PPE
supplies for every hospital but had I
been asked we would have granted it it's
it's that's not expensive that's not a
huge commitment but that comes out of
planning for the right sort of pandemic
so I you know all these questions about
Economic Policy we can have an argument
was it the right economic wrong I think
it's the right Economic Policy but the
real problem was
time spent quizzing the experts on what
potential pandemics were coming
and preparing for those in the right way
and the questions that would follow from
that
thank you
my lady that concludes my questions of
Mr Cameron um I know that priority today
um
permission has has been given to Miss
Mitchell King's Council on behalf of
Scottish covid bereaved families for
justice to ask a short series of
questions
um may she now be allowed to do that
certainly I would normally break now but
I think it's stenographer Carry On from
Miss Mitchell's questions
yes thank you very much spiritual
life
[Music]
Mr Cameron I'm senior Council instructed
by our annborne company for the Scottish
covered bereaved
you've made it clear both in your
written evidence and your evidence here
today that you understood that pandemics
were a very real threat and you might
not have understood the phrase or
remember the phrase clear and present
danger but you would agree with me that
as a tier one risk it certainly was
something that was immediate important
and potentially grave in terms of risk
yes
and we've also heard
that given pandemics have happened
throughout history it was a matter of
when and not if a pandemic would occur
yes your language indeed we will face an
outbreak like Ebola made it clear that
you understood effectively that a
pandemic was inevitable yes
you've also uh referred to I think here
and also in your statement about
taking a longer term strategic View and
trying to fix the roof while the sun is
shining
presumably because whilst things are
good you put plans in place so when the
pandemic arrives it'll allow those to
deal with it
to weather the storm safely yes
because presumably you appreciated that
failure to properly plan would be likely
to have a catastrophic effect for the
United Kingdom
yes
can I ask you to look at the following
document is document
inq00087193 and we're looking at page
seven of that document
while we're waiting for that document to
come up on screen
this is a document from the Public
Accounts Committee of the House of
Commons entitled the whole of government
response to covert 19.
now I'd like to draw your attention
please
a week arrives on screen
to The Heading conclusions and
recommendations
could you get by the microphones please
my little friend knows very well that
we're constrained by the uh the rules of
parliamentary privilege
not to be able to put parliamentary
material which includes Nao reports in a
way which calls into debate the merits
of whatever conclusions have been drawn
by the particular parliamentary body or
anything said in fact in the chamber
of House of Commons so I'm just a bit
concerned that we may be breaching
parliamentary privilege by getting down
this line of examination well there's
certainly um a way Milady that I can ask
the questions
um without having to refer to those
documents so I'll be able to do that and
that way and I'm obliged to my learner's
friend for highlighting that before that
route has gone down thank you
well while you were in government and
when you were prime minister
did you make any plans
for the effect economically on
individuals in the United Kingdom
well I think as I answered earlier that
the two answers to that one is
the biggest thing was to get the British
economy and the public finances in a
state where they were capable of
responding to the next Crisis because
just as I answered earlier you know we
will have another pandemic
we will have another economic crisis of
some sort whether it's a recession or a
banking crisis or a Insurance who knows
what it will be the question is
do you have the capacity do you have the
spare capacity to suddenly borrow
another 10 15 20 of your GDP to help the
country and help people through it
that's the key question and that was
very much in my mind when we drew up the
plan to reduce the budget deficit and
get the debt GDP ratio under control
because
that's the responsible thing to do
the second answer is that as I think I
said in the National risk assessments
um there's quite a lot of material about
National Business resilience planning
working out
if you had a pandemic flu and even with
the with the pandemic flu we were
looking at which was would have had you
know hundreds of thousands of of deaths
and a huge effect on the economy what do
you do to help the various sectors of
the economy to recover So to that extent
yes there was a plan well your plan was
about the country what I was asking you
about and if I would ask you to focus on
the question was was there a plan made
for the economic impact on individuals
during a pandemic
well until you know exactly what
pandemic you face and whether you're
going to need to
um have people at home so you have a
furlough plan or you're going to have to
um act in a different way and you might
need to cut vat or change tax rates so
you know you need to have those
decisions can be made very quickly as
they were to the credit of the
chancellor when the pandemic hit but you
need to have the capacity in the economy
to do it
you clearly understood that the effect
of a pandemic might mean that people
were sick and weren't able to attend
work and businesses might have problems
yes
did you while you were in government put
any plan make any plans have any
conversations about what a furlough
might look like about what an economic
plan might look like where those
discussions had what I I can't remember
every discussion I had but I have seen
that in the National risk assessments
those sorts of things are looked at and
obviously in government when we were
looking at the threat of
pandemics or the threat of terrorist
attacks or the threat of something work
you know a major terrorist attack that
could take out a whole
City what would you do
in order to keep the economy going and
help people yes we did have those
conversations well I'm actually
specifically asking about those not at
the level that you're talking about I'm
talking about the individuals
who would not be able to go to work I'm
talking about the businesses that needed
to keep going
there were no concrete plans made
for that correct
well I mean you keep asking this I mean
I think I have to go back over the
national risk assessments I think there
were looking at individual sectors and
businesses and what would have to be
done
um so I I but uh maybe I can look at
that again and and give you a written
answer because I I I I don't want to say
there's something in them that there
isn't but I think they are they do
address some of these questions I'm sure
the inquiry would be greatly assisted if
you can find anything in relation to the
economic planning uh um
um but as of at today's date you can't
think of anything well I I can which is
if you have a strong economy and good
public finances you can flex your tax
your benefit system your spending
um that you can you have them enormous
Financial capacity of the British state
to act and help people
we now know that over
227 000 people died from covert and
we've heard evidence that the UK was not
prepared for a pandemic we've heard
evidence that after years of
underfunding cuts inequalities that this
impacted upon the devastating scale of
the death
in retrospect do you agree as prime
minister there had been wise for you to
plan for for economic impacts of the
pandemic and I mean by that the
furloughs and the business schemes so
you had a plan ready-made off the peg
available to implement so the government
was not left scrabbling around and
making ad hoc decisions in very fast
time right at the very moment when they
could have better been focusing on other
matters like the pandemic
I I just I'm afraid with great
perspective I'm not sure I agree with
the premise of the question I mean the
furlough scheme came in very quickly
very boldly and made an enormous
difference
and that was possible because we had the
financial capacity to do it but it
proves the point that you know for all
the plans you can have in the world
until you actually see the nature of the
pandemic and how it's developing
planning in advance exactly what your
economic responses are going to be is
only of of I would argue limited use it
would certainly be useful though to have
an economic response which took into
account something that you knew it would
happen which would people would be sick
and off work
yes but you what you don't know is are
you going to have a pandemic where
people who are symptomatic stay at home
or are you going to have a pandemic
where effectively the committee I'm sure
will decide whether right or wrong you
have a lockdown and everybody stays at
home so these are two you know
different types of pandemic requiring
two different types of economic response
despite what you see about planning do
you accept that when the pandemic
arrived the UK still found itself in a
situation where Essential Medical items
such as the ventilators stockpiles of
PPE hygiene control were not still
readily available well clearly there
were problems when the pandemic hit and
I think this does go back to
[Music]
um
identifying the different sorts of
pandemic that could hit you and planning
for each one and I I come back again and
again to this issue about
you know asymptomatic transmission of an
easily transmitted virus which is yes
lethal but much lower than MERS or lower
than Ebola and that's what we had and
um you know more if more time if more
questions have been asked inside the
system or challenging the system about
that then lots of consequences about PPE
and about surge capacity and Nightingale
hospitals and all the rest of it a lot
of consequences might have followed
so we were not only preparing for the
wrong pandemic but the wrong questions
were being asked can I ask so I think it
was more we were we were not I think
it's wrong to say we're praying for the
wrong pandemic I mean there could easily
have been there could still be a
pandemic flu and it's good that we have
been prepared for that but as Oliver
letman says in his evidence and George
Osborne says in his and they put it
perhaps better than I have a lot of time
we're spending spent preparing for a
pandemic that didn't happen rather than
one that did happen in retrospect Mr
Cameron do you think that as prime
minister your government's failure to
plan for the economic impacts on
individuals and businesses plead any
role in the catastrophic loss of lives
on the storm of covid-19 arrived in the
UK some four years after your departure
well I'm desperately sorry about the
loss of life
um so many people have lost people that
are close to them and there's been a lot
of of heartache and obviously that
continues and people also suffered in
all sorts of ways through the pandemic
and that's why this inquiry is
is so important I've tried to be as
Frank as I can and as open as I can
about the things my government did that
helped put in place the right
architecture for looking at these
threats uh The Horizon scanning the
units we put in place the exercises that
were undertaken but I've also tried to
be frank about
the you know the things that were missed
um and and the thing I struggle with is
is is
why they were missed because
you know it was not asking questions
about
asymptomatic transmission of an easily
infectious disease with a certain level
of lethality that we hadn't seen before
but nonetheless might appear
um that's that that is you know that is
I think where
um some of the difficulties flow from I
mean there's then a whole question of
how the response is actually managed in
practice which I know the committee will
come on to
I have no further question
that concludes Mr Cameron's evidence
thank you very much for your help Mr
Cameron thank you I'm being encouraged
to break now please so the sonographer
can rest her overwork Fingers
um I'm also being encouraged to resume
at 12 45 and then sit till 1 30 then
have lunch
is that going to cause people
serious problems
if it doesn't then I will return at 12
45. thank you my lady all right
my lady just before we return and the
evidence may I invite you to provide
permission for Mr Cameron's witness
statement to be published it was put on
up on screen at the beginning of his
evidence thank you very much
[Applause]
lady Sir Christopher wormall please
sorry to keep you waiting
no problem
I do solemnly since
sincerely and truly
clear and affirm at the end
of the evidence I shall give
it shall be the truth
it's the whole truth
and nothing but the truth
I use a Christopher wormald I am
thank you very much Christopher for
coming today
um whilst you give evidence could you
please remember to keep your voice up
not not merely so that we can all hear
you but also for the purposes of the
transcript and the aid of this
stenographers if I ask you a question
which I've not made sufficiently clear
please do ask me to put it again
there will be a break at lunchtime and
it's possible that you may get the
benefit of a break in the middle of the
afternoon depending on where we get to
you have provided a number of statements
to this inquiry
um unusually named statements first
second fourth sixth and seventh
I don't think that um
we need to put them all up on the screen
but obviously Milady could they all be
published
each one of them has been signed by you
with the usual declaration
as to the truth of their content
and
plainly you adopt them all as part of
your evidence
yes
I'd like to start please with addressing
some of the structures
which
underpin the approach of the Department
of Health and Social care
to its
pandemic related duties
and
it's convenient perhaps if you could
just give us a very brief resume both of
your
position of the Department of Health and
Social care and of your career in the
Civil Service yes thank you um if I if I
may before I start I would like to
reiterate the Department's heartfelt
sympathy for everyone who suffered in
the uh in the covid epidemic uh both
both directly and indirectly and also
add thanks to the uh amazing staff in
the Health and Care sector who helped us
uh uh get through and I wanted to put
both those things on a record uh yes I
am permanent Secretary of the Department
of Health and Social care which I have
in our position I have held since uh
2016 prior to that I was the permanent
Secretary of the department for
Education between 2012 and 2016 and
before that I worked in a variety of
roles at the cabinet office between
2009 uh to yes 2009 and 2
2012 where I should put on record that a
number of the conversations you had with
the last uh witness on I was supporting
the Coalition including on a number of
the decisions they took around austerity
and the issues that were discussed uh
this morning which I ought to note
um and prior to the cabinet office I was
director general for uh local government
and regeneration at uh Department of
communities and local government as it
was then called and then a whole series
of other roles in the Civil Service of
more Junior levels uh prior to that all
right thank you
the general scheme of things in a
department
particularly one as important as the
Department of Health and Social care
well where does a permanent secretary
come in the General Order of Things
um well you have three roles as a
permanent uh secretary well I will say
these in a department like the uh
Department of uh uh Health at this time
uh which is a largely a strategy and
Policy Department uh in this period
we've already had uh heard some
discussion about the changes in the 2012
act before that it was a much more
operational Department
I'm I'm so sorry to interrupt um the
question was really where is the
permanent circuit and the general order
of things I'm going to ask you questions
about the role of the Department of
Health and Social care and and of course
we'll yeah we'll go into those issues
okay
um sorry is it important to the role
that you play but um but yes
um you do um uh largely three things so
you are chief executive of the
organization which means you lead the uh
the staff of the uh Department uh you
are the chief advisor on policy uh to
the uh Secretary of State and you are
the accounting officer for the budgets
that Parliament delegates to the uh uh
to the Department
the
inquiry has heard evidence that the
Department of Health and Social care
was designated as what is known as a
responder in fact a category one
responder
um under the Civil contingencies act
2004 in fact the Secretary of State yes
in the Department of Health and Social
care is the designated responder
can you just assist inquiry with with
the extent to which it is understood in
the department
what
the extent of those obligations are
under the Civil condition s Act is this
an obligation which is placed on the
Secretary of State personally or is it
an obligation that is discharged by the
department as a whole
um well
legally the department is elimination of
the secretary of state so in almost all
cases the legal powers of the department
are
vested in the Secretary of State
personally
um secretaries of State discharge those
functions
um normally via their department so they
so they are effectively individual
indivisible so if you asked people
within the department they would say
that the department is a category one uh
responder
in the way that you describe that every
secretary of state has any number of
ministerial obligations both by way of
being in charge of a department
both by way of
discharging obligations imposed on him
or her under our constitutional
structures but also
a fair few number of legal obligations
of the type
to which I've just made reference under
civil contingencies Act
to what extent our secretaries of State
reminded or constantly informed that
they are subject to direct legal
obligations as well as their
normal ministerial obligations you would
normally be um
have your legal responsibilities explain
to you when you come in to uh office
that that would be the most uh important
moment and then obviously if you're an
experienced Secretary of State uh you
will largely be aware of what your legal
responsibilities are
so as a department but then directly as
the Secretary of State
the the department
was under a legal obligation as a
category one responder to assess the
risk of emergencies occurring
plan for contingency planning put into
place emergency plans and business
continuity Arrangements
make information available to the public
share information and cooperate with
local responders to enhance emergency
response coordination and efficiency
measures so
there was a
a fairly extensive list of specific
obligations placed on the department yes
that is filled a civil contingency
that's correct with one uh addition uh
the other responsibility of the
department was to assure itself
um of um the Readiness of other category
one uh responders in this context uh
mainly NHS England and public health uh
England as our two main delivery agents
and we discharge that function by having
a uh full-time permanent civil servants
who work specifically on emergency
response which is uh in the directorate
led by Emma Reed who I believe the
inquiry is going to hear from uh
directly so how those how those Powers
play out in practice is by the
allocation of resources within the
department of Staff whose primary
responsibility
is to act as that category one responder
and as we've uh uh put in various of our
witness statements there are a whole
series of incidents in which they
respond in that indeed but the ensure
Assurance piece is a very important
addition to the list to read out
and do those legal obligations apply to
all emergencies or or just health
related
for example pandemic emergencies
um well there were
um
uh it's it's easy to work with
simplified but there are
um
things which are clearly a health lead
because the heart of the emergency is a
um uh is a uh it is a set of health
issues uh for example the uh recent
monkeypox outbreak I think would be in
that category and then there were a
large number of things where health is
one player
in
an emergency that is Led from somewhere
else so something like a terrorist
incident
um obviously there is a Health Service
response but it's LED from elsewhere now
I say it's easy to simplify because of
course
the the nature of emergencies means it's
not always that clear-cut so the
novichok poisonings for example would be
an example where there was a clear
security lead on the security aspects
and then a huge Health lead on the
health consequences
my question related in fact the legal
duties under the Civil contingencies act
those duties apply on a department as
yeah the Secretary of State in relation
to any emergency do they know they're
not limited to a health emergency but in
practice for reasons I'll come on to in
a moment
the Department of Health and Social care
is obviously concerned with health yes
that's correct and the reason it's
concerned particularly with health
emergencies is that under this
governmental system of
risk identification
risk ownership
and
departmental response to emergencies
the dhsc and before the Department of
Health was the lead government
Department
relating to pandemic risks that's
correct yes now lead government
department is um that that's an
administrative designation rather than a
legal designation yes yes
and therefore is the lead government
Department your department was
responsible for leading
the government's work
on risks
which concerned you directly and for
which you had to be responsible to use a
terrible word risks which you owned yes
that's correct and that meant that you
would be involved in the system of risk
assessment in relation to pandemics
dealing with other government
departments of course in relation to how
they respond
dealing of course with how your own
Department would respond in the event of
a pandemic
and through various other parts of the
government ensuring
and I refer that to the cabin office
role and the role of the resilience and
emergencies division in the department
of leveling up and housing and
communities making sure that all the
other parts of the government
do what they're meant to do that's
correct that's part of the heavy burden
of being the lead government Department
that's correct
and of course in this pandemic which
Milady is inquiring into your department
was the lead government Department uh
certainly in the planning phase and the
initial uh response I mean obviously
becomes a more of an issue for your uh
for your second module it does obviously
the owners of activity moved to a
national scale in this particular crisis
as it does in many others yes
and
may we take it from your answers
therefore Christopher that because of
this legal obligation because of the
fact that your department was the lead
government department when it came to
pandemic related matters risks planned
response planned recovery anything to do
with pandemics
this was during
the 10 years leading up to the pandemic
of core importance to your department
um yes I mean obviously as you said
earlier the department has many many UH
responsibilities across the Health and
Care
sector which is of course a huge sector
but this is one of the very important
responsibilities that we hold
in your
Department there is a directorate called
the e
p h p director I think it's the
emergency preparedness and health
protection
yes directory yeah I mean it's um it's
had a variety of names as I'm sure
you've and acronyms which I'm sure you
have uh identified but basically yes
there is a directorate that is
responsible for emergency preparedness
and our oversight of Health protection
as you describe predict much throughout
including pandemic preparedness yes
correct yes
um and and obviously
we've we've seen that there were a
significant number of bodies and
entities and boards and so on and so
forth both within your department and
also connected to your department arms
length bodies and so on yeah
who are focusing or which we're focusing
on pandemic influenza preparedness
so one of them and we had evidence of
this last week the pandemic influenza
preparedness board pip
was that a
dhsc-led program or was that a
cross-government that one is uh the uh
the dhsc lead program there was a second
board which I'm sure will come on to
which was uh cross-government
and was that pit board
um chaired in fact by Clara Swinson to
whom you've referred who was the then
director general for Global health and
health protection from whom we'll be
hearing perhaps later today this
afternoon uh yes from the point of her
appointment which I think was towards
the end of 2016 and that board first met
in October 2007 you may recall um well I
don't I I I I don't think it for me
I'm pulled by the record yes okay
another board was the pandemic influenza
preparedness board and as we've heard in
evidence that was a board which was a
cross-government board which was set up
by order of the National Security
Council
thrc threats highlights resilience and
contingencies committee chaired by the
then prime minister Theresa May in 2017.
that's correct and was that a board on
which the dhsc had a place and which
considered directly influenza planning
yeah I mean it was a um it was the part
of um uh the follow-up to um the uh the
cygnus exercise
and it was the main body charged with
taking forward uh the uh learning and
actions from
that exercise and it was code shared
between the cabinet office and dhsc
recognizing that there were
recommendations that went in directly
into the Health Service and those for uh
wider government
within the internal management of your
department
did the various individuals and
employees who were contributing to these
and other boards report up to through
you to a departmental board
um
I'm not sure we pulled up to is the
correct uh terminology uh so forgive me
so well no I mean this is a um uh
I'm not quite sure what the right well
I'll I'll simply so Christopher will you
allow me to rephrase yeah well let me
rephrase the question in your department
as part of its internal management
structure is there an overarching body
called the department yes there is now
um as I said earlier
um all the uh legal powers are in fact
vested in the uh the secretary of state
so departmental boards and sorry this is
why I was struggling to find the correct
words uh they are not like the boards of
arms length bodies all the boards or
private companies or charities in that
they do not hold any decision making or
if I can do a um uh responsibilities so
they are legally purely advisory boards
to the Secretary of State who exercises
uh uh all the uh the legal trials or all
the legal Powers so they are important
but they are important in that advisory
function as opposed to being a
decision-making uh body but subject to
the legal powers vested in and imposed
upon the Secretary of State personally
the departmental board is the most
senior board or Advisory Group within
the whole department is it not yes but
it's very important to note that that
does not mean it is the conduit of
advice that goes to the Secretary of
State in the vast majority of cases as I
think I set out in my first witness
statement the basis of uh departmental
decision making is the submission system
to the Secretary of State so what what I
don't want to give the impression of is
that Secretary of State decision making
is particular advised by the people who
doesn't meet that often but you are
correct that it is the highest
Committee in the department and may I
just observe that I didn't suggest that
it was about giving advice
it is however a body which addresses
matters of the greatest import of the
greatest importance
to the department as a whole matters
which could imperil the very existence
of the department for example the major
risks to its functioning as operation go
to that level do they not uh yes so um
the uh so the Department's risk register
is a uh normally a standing item of the
board and one of the board and
particularly the non-executive members
of the board's role is to critique what
the department is is doing on all those
issues as a challenge function and as I
say decision making uh sits elsewhere
and like many entities and Boards the
board has a risk register which it has
half an eye on or a full eye which tells
it which risks pose the greatest threat
to the whole entity the whole department
which risks need to be focused upon by
the board and a register is of course
where the risks come in the general
order of things and what has been done
to mitigate those risks that that that's
correct in general and in a general
sense yeah and quickly uh identified
earlier what the board does is it sits
on top of a structure that assesses uh
those risk and subcommittees that do so
and so the board examines matters that
are of the Grievous importance to the
department and one such matter it's
examined by way of a risk Deep dive was
the issue of major infection diseases
which it did in September of 2016. uh
yes
could we have please 22738
departmental board risk Deep dive dated
we can see 28 September 2016 and then
page two please paragraph one
in keeping with the departmental risk
guidance each quarter a risk from the
departmental high-level risk register is
to be selected for a more in-depth
discussion at the departmental board the
aim of the discussion is consider in
more detail the mitigations for a
particular risk which might not
otherwise be discussed this quarter the
risk of an outbreak of a major
infectious disease has been selected for
the first of these risk deep Dives
so Christopher it is self-evident that
the risks selected for a deep dive
will only be those risks which pose the
greatest threat
to the department and
um and as he's shown in this
presentation though in fact two risks
that uh that uh fell into this category
one which was the uh risk of uh
influenza pandemic and one was what is
known as the risk of a high consequence
infectious diseases and at the bottom of
the page we can see the key question for
the departmental board is how much money
time and effort do we want to invest in
our insurance against these risks and
the blurb sets out how the national risk
assessment
that's no longer in existence because it
was
done away with and combined into the
National Security risk assessment in
2019 to which my ladies heard referenced
sets out a very severe reasonable worst
case scenario for pandemic flu there was
then a debate about the substantial
expenditure on countermeasures
and then at the second bullet point in
the event of a major disease Outbreak
The the department of health because you
were known as the Department of Health
then and then
the directorate to which you've already
made
reference
the
ephpp directorate would be very rapidly
overwhelmed
should we do more to raise awareness of
the risk and a plan for immediate
mobilization of a large number of staff
and then this the lack of a national
Forum to support and overseas planning
and response in the social care sector
poses challenges is there more that can
be done to provide Direction strengthen
coordination so important serious issues
were being raised in the department for
consideration by its highest level board
in this deep dive
all related to in Broad terms pandemic
planning that is correct
uh I would say pandemic and high
consequence infectious disease
heart related
the
that is the uh the minute or rather the
um the presentation
um if we could just have a quick look at
page eight please on the document
and if you could zoom in please
some Figures were provided to the board
on the likely consequences of a severe
pandemic 30 million people symptomatic
three hundred thousand to 1.2 million
requiring hospital care 75 300 000
required Critical Care Peak illness 7.2
million people
impact on the economy massive lost
working hours huge societal disruption
extensive
could we have the minutes please of the
meeting
this was a meeting dated the 29th of
September so one day later which these
points were discussed
departmental board draft minutes present
Chris wormald
that's you of course
and members of your team
apologies Jeremy Hunt Secretary of State
for health
could we have please page one
Chris wormald opened the meeting noting
apologies for members there was no
ministerial attendance due to the House
of Commons summer recess in the upcoming
Party Conference season
and then page three please
and the second bullet point members
agreed that the effectiveness of the
board was linked to ministerial
engagement as much as it was to
executive and non-executive engagement
has thought the balance between
executive non-executive and mistrial
members was important
though there's a level of ambivalence
amongst executive members of the
proposed reduction in their membership
some suggested it may be appropriate for
them to attend the board for the
discussions on performance risk and
Horizon scanning
and then the next bullet point please
members were concerned by the Secretary
of State's continuing lack of Engagement
with the board
Chris wormald explained to members that
ministerial attendance the Department of
Education departmental board had been
compulsory and enforced by the Secretary
of State
he also advised that ministerial code
requires secretary's estate to chair
their departmental boards
on the proposal the Secretary of State
nominated Junior Minister's chair in his
absence members noted that both David
Prime Philipp Dunn had appropriate board
level experience
what steps did you take to ensure that
the Secretary of State for your
department attended future board
meetings addressing matters of the
highest importance such as pandemic
planning
um I don't recall having a specific
conversation with the Secretary of State
on that point and I don't have a record
of uh uh of doing so uh the secretary of
state would have been aware of the
meeting would also have been shown the
minutes or the meeting I I assume but as
I say I don't have a Rick Ward or
directly speaking the Secretary of State
about that matter this was a board that
you were the ex-officio head of released
by virtue of your name being first on
the list of attendees
at that meeting members expressed
concern
about the Secretary of State's
continuing lack of Engagement
why was that not a matter that you
brought to his direct and immediate
attention in this
issue
um
it's very it's very difficult to comment
on a uh a negative as I say I don't
recall
um having a conversation we undoubtedly
had conversations about the board
um I don't recall
um
discussing this particular board meeting
so we definitely had conversations about
the board and ministerial attendance as
I say I don't recall uh raising this one
specifically
it can't be very usual Sir Christopher
for members of departmental board to
express concern about their own
Secretary of State
[Music]
I think it's uh I don't think it is
so why didn't you bring it to his
specific attention
[Music]
um
as I say
um I don't have a record of uh uh doing
so
um and uh I therefore cannot recall what
was
um at uh um was my thought process at
the uh uh at the time I
all right I hesitate to guess what I was
thinking but I suspect I was uh thinking
that I would deal with it in the general
rather than the specific but that is a
um uh
um that is my post-talk rationalization
by which you mean
well as I say we were um uh I remember
having discussions uh with the Secretary
of State about the board in the in
general
um and
um I suspect I was thinking that was the
best way to address uh the issue rather
than a discussion about this specific uh
uh board meeting
as I don't have a record of uh having
done that so I can't claim that I did
page six please
and then further down the page
just a little bit further up please I'm
sorry too far down
paragraph 24 the department has been
planning for a major outbreak or
pandemic for many years and the United
Kingdom is recognized as one of the most
prepared countries in the world
for example it had invested more in
antiviral stockpiles than most other
countries
the antiviral stockpiles was in the main
Tamiflu the brand name for an
anti-influenza pandemic
antiviral
is that correct uh that's my
understanding yes
so although it had invested more in
antiviral stockpiles than most other
countries the stockpiles for antivirals
was concerned only with
providing a countermeasure to pandemic
influenza
uh in that case yes so the department is
taking part in exercise cygnus which
would take place between October and
20th of October and be modeled on a
pandemic scenario
it had been canceled twice
we'll come to cygnus in a moment
one paragraph further down please
it was more likely than not that not
even that that it was more likely than
not that even a moderate pandemic would
overrun the system
at the extreme there would be
significant issues if it became
necessary to track or quarantine
thousands of people a decision to fund
high-end quarantine facilities had
already been deferred by ministers
so Christopher we will look in detail
over the next two hours on what steps
were taken by the department between now
and 2016 and 2020 when the pandemic
struck
would you agree
that by January of 2020
the system was not even then capable
of dealing with even a moderate pandemic
um
I would have quite a nuanced answer well
that question
um
yes indeed
please answer that's right at um uh I
think a significant number of steps uh
had been uh taken
um at the time
um and um this comes out in the power
graph that you uh emphasized uh before
uh we believed uh that we had uh uh good
and very good by International standards
procedures in place
and I believe that those were
rational things to think given the
evidence uh advice and resources that we
had at the time
um if you ask me now uh with the benefit
of uh hindsight of having dealt uh with
the pandemic
um there are a uh well a a large number
of things uh that I would have wanted to
have added as it were but that is with
the benefit of hindsight so I would
distinguish between what we thought was
rational uh at the time which was as I
say set out in the uh the previous
paragraph that you uh uh said and and
what we would think now based on what we
now know the other thing I would add
about this
um and this may have been an error but
it was certainly what we thought was
um an awful lot of our thinking and the
thinking that was in place when I
arrived at the department was focused on
the cygnus exercise and that where we
expected all these questions to go into
that exercise and the uh follow-up I'm
sorry I'm sorry that's a sort of nuanced
answer but like trying to set out well
what what I think we thought at the time
and why separately from what we now
think uh is an appropriate Way Forward
if that is if that if that is um uh
understandable so Christopher it forms
no part of this inquiry to examine with
hindsight
what other decisions
could have been made
or were made or not made
but in 2016 this departmental board was
warning in the clearest terms it was
more likely than not that even a
moderate pandemic would overrun the
system so there is no issue of hindsight
here that was a prospective warning
the system
would likely not cope
um yes which is exactly why there was
the proposal and indeed the uh the
actuality of exercise sickness yes
exercise sickness paragraph six of its
final report said this
the UK's preparedness and response in
terms of its plans policies and
capability were not sufficient to cope
with the extreme demands of a severe
pandemic that would have a United
kingdom-wide impact across all sectors
so exercise cygnus did not come
in any way to relieve the problem that
was identified in paragraph 25 it
reported again
that systemically the system would not
be sufficient
so what was done after cygnus to ensure
that the system would be sufficient
um well there was a whole program of
work post signals that we have mentioned
already led by the um
[Music]
pandemic influential preparedness board
that we discussed earlier the
cross-government board whose job it was
to take forward the uh the findings of
the um uh of the exercise
career please paragraph 26.
[Music]
all decisions in response to an outbreak
or pandemic would need to be made by the
department of the Department of State
though arms-length bodies will have
their role to play there were however
concerns about how resilient the
somewhat fragmented system would be
especially in light of previous or
future funding cuts
by January 2020
the system remained fragmented did it
not
um it's legal structure
um as set out in the 2012 Act and the
2014 uh Care Act uh to governing pieces
of uh legislation haven't changed no
the legal structure under that act
and the legal structure under the Civil
contingencies act 2004 had not
materially altered had it
uh those two so the the two acts which
is where the governing acts of how we
run the system the 2012 Act and the 2014
ACT for health and then social care uh
remained in place yes and then as you
know these civil engineers act hadn't
changed
the whole system of a lead government
Department
having local authorities and local
resilience forums being supervised and
liaise with by the resilience and
emergencies division of the Department
of leveling up and
housing in communities hadn't changed no
the cabinet office position hadn't
changed through its resilience
directorate itself to exercise control
by political persuasion and other means
over other government departments
um a little more than political
persuasion but no it hadn't changed
the Department of Health and Social care
was responsible for the funding and the
general guidance
funding of and general guidance for
local authorities but of course local
authorities who are concerned with
the social adult social care sector fall
out with the direct
functions of your department uh that's
correct so the 2014
Care Act which broadly maintained uh the
previous arrangements for adult social
care sets out that it is a a local
Authority lid and funded
service so it's it's not correct we
oversold the funding the funding is
locally raised and it gives a quite a
limited set of powers to
to central government
mainly through the inspection of care
providers
not not local Authority commission as I
say because that is something we've uh
we have changed so it was a largely
located
system with the Department having in
responsibilities around the legal
framework and around the uh uh
inspection as implemented by CQC and so
Sir Christopher
having therefore accepted that in no
significant regard had there been any
change
to the fragmented nature of the system
as our 2016 would you agree that this
system remains similarly fragmented
still by January 2020.
um I'll say the so the the legal
position uh on all those matters uh had
not changed in this board meeting Sir
Christopher concerns weren't being
expressed about
the dry nature of the legal obligations
being placed on the various parts of the
government machine concern was being
expressed about
how resilient the somewhat fragmented
system would be whether it would COPE in
Practical terms
that wasn't just an issue about legal
obligations was it
uh no no um I was answering the specific
question you so there were no changes
were there significantly to how
resilient the system would be between
2016 and 2020 it remained fragmented
yeah that's true thank you and you are
accepting it was fragmented I got the
feeling that maybe you weren't accepting
so Christopher it was fragmented
um I don't think there is
um
uh any uh any dispute that it was
fragmented and indeed
um the um the whole point of the 2012 uh
act uh was to reduce uh the level of
central control uh over particularly the
uh NHS
and to run the system
much more as a uh and I apologize for
using the Jog and as a quasi market so
the idea of that act was
um to have operational Freedom within
the NHS
and for the system to be uh based around
a series of Commissioners and providers
as opposed to a top-down system of
Direct Control has had existed prior
2012. now with a
um whether you believe fragmented to be
a good or bad thing I don't think
there's any dispute that that was the
purpose of that uh set-off reforms
um uh is not a matter of dispute uh that
um social care is a locally run service
and therefore divided amongst the uh uh
uh top tier uh local authorities uh as
it get again you can debate whether that
is a good thing or a bad thing but I
don't think it's in doubt that it's a
thing
and there we must leave it well unless
you particularly wanted anything else on
this topic well as it happens I had one
more question on this documents and then
perhaps we can put it to one side
paragraph 25 there would be significant
issues if it became necessary to track
or quarantine thousands of people
is this the position Sir Christopher
that despite that issue the important
issue of quarantining being raised in
2016. by January 2020
whilst there was and had been a
continual debate
as to how to isolate individuals
in the event of a high consequence
infectious disease
there was and there never was any debate
about mass quarantining mass isolation
Mass quarantining was that
um well in the uh influenza plan uh to
um
the basis of uh that is a series of uh
uh voluntary uh what are known as mpis
which would have included those issues
what there was nothing I'm so sorry to
to interrupt
quarantining is as you know of course a
mandatory thing it's a mandatory
restriction was there any debate between
now the issue having been raised in 2020
of mandatory quarantining of significant
numbers of the population
uh not in the context of a pandemic
well we're not really concerned with
quarantining outside the pandemic in
this inquiry so the answer is no
um not in the contact pandemic I'm sure
we will come on to but there are
important in interactions uh between the
strategy for high consequence infectious
diseases and the uh uh
and the plans for a pandemic which I'm
sure we will discuss further
I think you said the issue haven't been
raised in 2020 I think you meant 2016.
thank you I did
uh very well we shall come back at 20
plus two please
Keith so Christopher maybe now turn
please to the risk assessment process
would you preferred earlier
as you've hopefully stated the
Department of Health and Social care was
the lead government Department
for pandemic risk and infectious disease
and so it was in the nomenclature the
risk owner
for those risks in the National Security
risk assessment it
provided information and was part of the
part of the process by which
the risk was those risks were identified
debated described in the paperwork
and also what the impacts
would be likely to be from those risks
the department owned
all aspects of the debate concerning
those two risks pandemic influenza risk
and
emerging infectious disease risk now
that's correct I mean the the process of
setting the risk and then agreeing the
reasonable worst case scenarios and all
those things I think has been described
in other statements I mean yes it's an
iterative process between the department
and the uh
the center and and the inquiry is aware
that the department obviously received
advice from both its internal scientists
it's
departmental Chief Scientific Advisor or
government Department Scientific Advisor
from a number of
external advisors
external bodies these risk assessments
were were poured over by a multitude of
people and body yeah that is uh that
that that's correct so the process we
don't need the full data we just agree
with the proposition that they were that
they were of course examined at Great
length by your department which is
responsible for them and also with the
assistance of of internal and external
advisors and scientists yes that's
correct all right
now we need to look then at the actual
documentation so could we please have
inq147769
this should be the what was then called
the national risk assessment
and and Milady the
the government has has kindly
Declassified parts of this
internal National risk assessment for
the purposes of this inquiry
that is why so Christopher says official
sensitive at the top but we are looking
at it today and this is the 2016 version
and it was the national risk assessment
then but in 2019
the two forms of the assessment the
national risk assessment and the
National Security risk assessment were
brought together were they not yeah
that's my understanding all right
so can we look then please at page seven
the national risk assessment towards the
bottom of the page is a strategic
medium-term planning tool risks are
risks captured within the NRA the
national risk assessments are examples
of civil emergencies that could
plausibly affect the United Kingdom
within its territorial boundaries in the
next five years
crucial all risks are assessed using a
consistent
evidence-based approach what is an
evidence-based approach
um I think it's exactly what it says on
the tent said that it should be on the
basis of expert opinion modeling and the
uh available evidence
an approach that isn't based on
available evidence isn't much of an
approach is it
um well I mean
um uh government is sometimes in the
situation where it has to take decisions
despite lack of evidence
um at um so
um that does happen but if you're doing
this kind of assessment yes
um you would expect it to be
evidence-based and each risk is
considered on the basis of a reasonable
worst case scenario
it's intended to provide an illustrative
example of the worst plausible
manifestation of the risk in question
and it's based on two scores impact
which determines the severity of the
consequences and likelihood which is
more concerned with non-malicious risks
hazards or plausibility which is
concerned with malicious
threats determining the expected
recurrence rate of the risk over the
next five years and then if you just go
down the bot a bit further on the page
please
see that we have the hedging impact
determined on the basis of collating
information about severity of economic
losses and so on and so forth page nine
please
there is a chart at the top of the page
and
along the bottom of that chart
we have likelihood or plausibility we
can ignore
likelihood we're concerned with
plausibility because we're dealing with
hazards a pandemic rather than a for
example a terrorist threat
and on the left-hand side impact and at
the top we can see for medium high
likelihood
but catastrophic impact
pandemic influenza
thank you
and for medium high
with medium-high
Ood and moderate impact emerging
infectious diseases is that correct
that's correct
if we could scroll back out please and
look at the bottom half of the page you
can see that there's a second child
and in relation to
pandemic influenza risk because it falls
in the top part of the above chart in
the catastrophic range
there is a circled area in this chart
called high impact risks in relation to
which the government is expected to
supplement generic capabilities of a
specific contingency plans
scroll back out please
because in emerging infectious diseases
was only in moderate impact as opposed
to significant or catastrophic it didn't
fall within the Shaded area for which
the government was expected to produce a
specific contingency plan that's correct
uh yes all right
page 10 please
planning assumptions were then drawn up
so once you'd identified likelihood and
you'd identified impact and you could
see where your risk came on the on the
top chart
planning assumptions were then made on
what the common consequences of a number
of risks might be if they came to pass
so that everybody could understand the
realistic worst case scenario and plan
accordingly is that correct uh yes
so there's an example given at the
bottom of the page risks that could lead
to mass casualties either an industrial
accident or a terrorist attack or
flooding or public disorder
if you group those risks together the
planning assumption would be therefore a
thousand casualties because that's the
worst of those four particular risks
which are grouped together do you agree
yes all right could we then please have
page 23
page 23 gives us for 2016.
the likelihood and the top chart and
impact of the tourists of which we're
most concerned h23 which is you agree
pandemic influenza and below it h24 for
moderate impact and medium likelihood
emerging infectious diseases
that's correct
and then page 47 please
this is the more detailed description of
the pandemic influenza risk and we need
to look at this in detail
you see Sir Christopher on the top left
the overall assessment is very high is
it not yes and is that because
sorry
is that because in the top right hand
corner of the page the chart for
pandemic influenza
provides that the reasonable worst case
scenario which is that star
is right up at the top of the page with
medium to high likelihood but
catastrophic impact that's correct and
therefore because of the medium high
likelihood and the catastrophic impact
together an overall assessment is made
of it being very high
that's correct what is the arrow under
the star signify
uh now that I couldn't tell you all
right well that that's easy then in that
case I won't pursue that particular
point with you then in the wording you
can see there's a general description of
the pandemic influence a risk
a novel flu virus emerges up to 50 of
the population may experience symptoms
000 fatalities in total
absenteeism could reach 20 percent and
then these words in the sixth line
each pandemic is different and the
nature of the virus and its impacts
cannot be known in detail in advance
that is a description which falls in
this page under the heading of pandemic
influenza
but it is applicable to any pandemic or
any viral respiratory disease because
they all differ and the nature of the
virus and its impacts can't be known in
detail in advance
so my question to you is this please Sir
Christopher
the risk assessment approved
acknowledged
that the pandemic influenza risk
could be different in each case its
characteristics could vary depending on
transmission severity incubation period
available countermeasures and the like
and the impacts couldn't be known in
detail in advance
why was that same approach not applied
to a non-influenza pandemic which is
equally
could be a virus or a Coronavirus or
some other type of
infectious disease
well I mean as you have discussed with
other Witnesses this is of course one of
the um
uh the great questions that now
how it was discussed within
the department while I have been in it
and this may have been a wrong approach
but it was undoubtedly what people said
to each other was you had to have a
basis for planning and influenza was the
most likely most dangerous and
identified risk
and the approach
es
um I'm sorry uh it's my third lady and
um uh and
the uh the approach taken was
essentially uh ready for flu really for
anything would be the summary of um uh
what was uh uh what was thought and uh
this was built in as I'm sure you know
from to the uh original uh 2011 flu plan
uh which mentions the possibility of
other uh respiratory uh uh diseases
um and that would certainly uh the
thinking that was going on at the time
that you had to specify a risk and
influenza was chosen on that basis
um and that then
um were some other type of unpredictable
pandemic uh breakout you would adapt to
the flu plan uh based upon that approach
now as with some of my previous answers
um at um obviously we have learned a lot
um and um uh in terms of our learning
from the pandemic we are in a different
place but in terms of what was thought
at the time and then your question that
was the uh approach being taken in the
next paragraph it says there is no known
evidence for association between the
rate of transmissibility and severity of
infection
meaning it's possible that a new
influenza virus could be both highly
transmissible and cause severe symptoms
what your own departmental risk
assessment you owned this assessment was
saying
dealing with
pandemic influenza
there's no known evidence of association
between transmissibility and severity
which means just because something is
high transmissibility doesn't mean to
say it's going to be necessarily low
severity or high severity there are two
different issues
so it stands to reason that any disease
viral disease could be both
highly transmissible and very deadly
um that's what it says yes I mean you'd
need to
um you you have lots of them before the
inquiry you would need to ask our
epidemiologists for the silence behind
that but that's undoubtedly what it says
on the page but
that is a statement of known evidence
which applies to all infections all
viral respiratory diseases not just
influenza
so why didn't any any single person
in the plethora of individuals and and
entities who address this risk
assessment say well hang on
IFA influenza
disease a pathogen
can vary
quite significantly in its
characteristics incubation period
transmissibility stuttering or high
transmissibility
asymptomatic not symptomatic
and therefore
you just can't say what characteristics
is likely to have
surely that applies equally to
non-influenza pathogens
um in that because it's based on the
characteristics of a virus yeah
um and the chief medical officers
witness statements cover these points in
in detail do you agree that it was open
to anybody reading that paragraph to ask
that question
surely this applies to non-influenza
viruses as well
um well as I say that was the thinking
at the time that you wrote a plan for uh
flu
um and that uh if
um you got another type of pandemic then
you would be adapting uh the plan that
you had for flu for
um uh the disease that did occur and
as I say as he's covered in chief
medical officers statement a lot of that
has to be done when you know what the
disease you are facing uh is that was as
I say the thinking at the time all right
page 48 the next page please
so uh we're still in 2016.
now dealing with emerging infectious
diseases the overall assessment top left
is high not very high correct yes and in
the top right in the chart
for
likelihood plausibility again we're only
concerned here with likelihood the
reasonable worst case scenario star
reflects a medium-high likelihood same
as
influenza pandemic
but the impact is moderate rather than
catastrophic that's the difference isn't
it
yes though
um
as uh as I was saying before the break
and perhaps this is the moment to talk
about it but there isn't a hard and fast
uh distinction between High consequence
infectious diseases and then pandemics
indeed one can
become the other so the heart of this
strategy across those two uh things is
you can have an emerging infectious
disease
which you seek to contain
where you fail to contain it has the
possibility to become an epidemic or a
pandemic and that is of course what
happened exactly what happened with
kovid it was originally defined as a
high consequence infection yeah they're
Declassified as it became a pandemic
the arrows on this page page 48 signify
do they not that because
little may be known about the particular
characteristics of the emerging
infectious diseases
and because viral infections May differ
radically in terms of their incubation
period transmissibility severity and so
on and so forth
there is actually a chance
that the impact could be greater than
the reasonable worst case scenario and
that is why the top arrow is
insignificant the row for significant
yes I think I've understood the arrows
now that presumably is the bands of um
worst case scenario yeah so actually
whoever dropped this chart
was recognizing
that because with emerging infectious
diseases like all viruses it's
impossible to know in advance of any
degree of certainty what the
characteristics may be and therefore how
deadly or how transmissible
the disease would be
it was important to identify
the possibility that it could be more
significant than the reasonable worst
case scenario yes and as I uh uh as I
said you have to
um and Mrs also understanding how it has
always been thought about think about
those two strategies
um in um uh in uh in parallel so we had
one uh strategy this one
um which covered a wide range of um uh
possible diseases uh those classified as
a hcids
um a number of which have the
possibility as was the case with kovid
of becoming a uh uh uh becoming a
pandemic at
um
most of which and uh as on as you all
know from several of the witness
statements we have had a number of hcid
instances the vast majority of which
don't so on the question uh that I know
this inquiry has been looking at did we
only have a plan for flu that is not
correct we only had a pandemic flan pan
for flu to be used in the way I
described adapted in the light of the
pandemic that you had and then a wider
strategy uh a lot of which flowed from
the response to the Ebola crisis that
you were describing earlier about high
consequence infectious diseases and I
take the upper arrow in this case that
is the
um the transmission
from one category to the other that
would be a disease that would be on its
way to being epidemias pandemic so
likewise the one going downwards the
other way thank you Christopher so the
short answer is of a recessive respect
or suggest you with respect is that
there was a specific pandemic plan for
influenza oh yeah
but no specific pandemic plan for
anything that wasn't
influenza uh no well I mean that is
clearly factually correct for the reason
that I described it which I fully uh
fully appreciate uh may have um not been
the right approach and I'll say we're
taking a different approach now but just
in terms of what was the welcome sure
we'll come to now in a moment
could we scroll back out please from
page 48 if you
if you look at the bottom if you look at
the middle of the page there is then a
reference to the fact that there were
there had been more than 30 new or newly
recognized diseases
over the past 30 years
and there's a reference then to SARS and
then to MERS and Ebola
so the author of this document plainly
recognizes that there are a significant
number of new or newly recognized
diseases out there yeah and there had
been over 30 years and the arrows
indicate
properly that
there was a risk of something worse
happening than the reason or worst case
scenario because we're dealing here with
a generic description trying to be
applied to a specific future disease the
nature which you don't know yep all
right that is correct could we then look
please at 2019 which is
inq185135 on the eve of the pandemic
one eight five one three five
emerging infectious disease the risk
picture changes does it not between 2016
and 19.
uh yes because the chart now top right
hand corner has the top arrow for
possible catastrophic outcome of
emerging infectious disease two rows
above the reasonable worst case scenario
yeah and um I think I would say
um that is a more accurate uh picture or
the risk than the 2016 one as was
demonstrated in the uh in the pandemic
that we did
uh suffer so um clearly and as I said
um a high consequence infectious disease
can be on the way to being a uh a
pandemic catastrophic in terms so
Christopher of oh yeah massive
fatalities
well huge numbers of people infected
work absence impact on the economy yes
in so so
um in the translation between something
that begins as a high consequence
infectious disease and becomes an
epidemic or pandemic
um yes that it would have the same risk
profile as our pandemic risk it has
effectively become that and as I say
that is in practice what happened with
uh with code could we scroll back out
please
and towards the bottom of the page
you'll see a reference to a reasonable
worst case scenario
and a description of how the infection
would likely
develop outside the United Kingdom could
you scroll back out please
[Music]
and in the middle of the page
there's a debate over means of
transmissibility and so on
could we go forward one page please to
page two
there is any description of what the
reasonable worst case scenario described
above could lead to increased Demand on
specialist intensive care
localized disruption to routine health
creativities of outbreaks occur in
hospital settings just emphasize please
mentally so Christopher the reference to
hospital settings
further down the page specific
assumptions and strategic context
there is a likely High case fatality
rate for MERS it would be about 35
percent there's no effective treatment
the main control measure is the
implementation of effective infection
effective infection control so the
approach taken on this page is to say in
terms
because the reasonable worst case
scenario that star only has
medium impact not catastrophic
even if we assume there is no antiviral
there's no vaccine that there's a very
high case fatality rate 35 percent
the impact
is not going to be of the same order as
a influenza pandemic
it's of moderate impact
you'll be dealing with disease and
health settings Healthcare settings
possibility of infection there but it's
not going to run amongst the whole
population killing 35 percent
um no that is the um uh you have put
your finger on the difference between
um a high consequence of infectious
disease where you are dealing with small
numbers and you're seeking to contain it
where the greatest risk is in hospital
settings because doctors and nurses have
to be able to treat people who are
infected and there's greater risk of
transmissibility there
yes now
um I'm only
um I'm only cautious on my answers
because you will get much better answers
it's all right
other weaknesses on the epidemiology but
in terms of the concept
um
the high consequence infectious disease
strategy as I'll say is for where you
have small numbers and the attempt is to
contain and get it to zero and a
pandemic is effectively where contain
has failed
um also an epidemic will container has
failed and you are into the question of
how do you mitigate something that has
gone beyond your ability to contain it
we're focusing for the moment on the
risks not how you deal with a pandemic
once it's out there well the the only
thing I would say is those are um
uh that that question of can you contain
it and drive it to zero is Central to
the question of what the Whisk is
well
so Christopher the reason why it can be
controlled and reduced to zero is
because this risk assumption assumes
that it is not highly transmissible that
it's not going to run a mark through the
population and it can be controlled
correct that's great yes and that is the
difference between indeed between the
two categories could we go forward one
page please further to page three
there is then more debate about MERS and
SARS
and then in the middle of the page or
two thirds of the way down the page the
emergence of new infectious diseases is
unpredictable but appears to become more
frequent this may be linked to a number
of factors such as climate change the
increase in World Travel and so on and
so forth so there's a clear recognition
there isn't there that
new infectious diseases are
unpredictable and
have become more frequent correct ah yes
yes could you scroll back out please
and then at the bottom of the page
recovery and long-term implications
could we go forward one page again
please to page four
there is a description of variations
again a description of Ebola and
reference to Mars and SARS and then
please page eight
the consequences of this particular risk
broadly identified as it was
likelihood there is significant
uncertainty about the frequency with
which an emerging infection May develop
the ability to transmit from person to
person so there is a risk is there not
recognized in this document that a
non-influenza emerging infectious
disease May
be a high transmissibility pathogen it
may travel human to human readily yes
scroll back out please
but the fatalities the number of people
which were assumed in this document to
result from this disease is put it under
fatalities 200 no notice in excess
deaths and then further down the page
please
casualties UK total number two thousand
no notice in excess casualties
using the upper bounds 20 new meters
1800 excess
so even though
the arrow signified a risk of a
catastrophic outcome to a non-influenza
pandemic or a
non-influenza pathogen
even though the document recognized
that it could be human to human rapid
transmission and by implication that the
disease could spiral out of all control
it concluded only and I apologize to use
this language for using this language a
relatively few deaths by comparison to
the 820 000 deaths assumed in a
influenza pandemic
uh
now
um
I think we're in a slight danger of
getting lost in the terminology so
um
well
are you able to answer that question why
did those things being recognized being
apparent on the face of this document
was such a relatively limited conclusion
reached in terms of impact
because of the interrelationship between
those two uh identified risks and that's
the reason why the two risks are on the
uh National risk register so if you are
successful
containing a disease via your hcid
mechanisms
then you would be containing the risk at
these sorts of level but so Christopher
I apologize for interrupting if
the emerging infection does develop the
ability to transmit rapidly human to
human as those arrows identify
as that paragraph Under The Heading
likelihood confidence assessment States
there will be no question of containment
will there because it won't be oh no you
are into your epidemic pandemic risk
with the reasonable kind of reasonable
worst case scenarios identified for that
so that's what I mean why but why why
were the number of deaths put at two
thousand not eight hundred and twenty
thousand
this is where I think we may be at risk
of becoming lost in the terminology then
you have then you have two identical
risks who have effectively two epidemics
wrote pandemic risks for which the
outcomes will be the same massive loss
of life yeah collapse of the economy
huge millions of people infected
yes and as I say and that is not this
outcome on page eight is it no because
as you correctly uh uh identified
um these would be the outcomes if you
have successfully contained the disease
the outcomes if you were not
successfully contained the disease would
be in the reasonable worst case scenario
that we had identified for uh pandemic
influenza I I.E the disease in that case
would have translated as kovi did from
one being managed as an hcid with these
sorts of implications
into something that was in the pandemic
risk category with those sorts of uh
implications now um as I say I don't
know I'm not trying to get lost in the
terminology I'm trying to do is explain
the translation between those two so
your point I think is entirely correct
but it's the way it's reflected in the
risk register is how I have described it
it's the translation of a disease from
one category to another category so I'm
not sure I'm explaining myself very well
so Christopher in your own witness demon
do you accept that any new pathogen
transmitted by the respiratory route is
likely to share characteristics of the
influenza in that it may spread rapidly
via close proximity can travel rapidly
and there are a few easy immediate
counter measures yes
if that is so
then there is not likely to be any
control
as you correctly said
the non-influenza virus will react and
be apparent in just the same way as an
influenza pandemic widespread
devastating deadly
but that is simply not on the face of
this page is it no it's not on this page
but it is is it on any page so
Christopher that you know of well it's
in the um uh
uh I'll say I'm not sure I'm explaining
myself terribly well but
that is in the pandemic uh scenario so
if you look at the is it is
I apologize
yeah um so if you look at the types of
diseases uh discussed in this uh risk uh
mersals Ebola et cetera the ones that
you quoted uh they all were
um uh to uh contained
in the hcid
category that um now and
uh I have already pointed to this may
have been the floor a floor in the
approach and you've heard this from
other Witnesses but that was the
thinking that you have a risk that is
about can you contain uh the disease and
then you have a risk about a disease
that you have not uh contained which you
would manage in the same way
um as an influenza pandemic now as I say
it may have been incorrect thinking
um that
um uh ready for flu ready for anything
but that was how we were or how it was
being thought about the relationship
between these two things between the
thing that you want to contain and you
try as hard as you can to contain and is
the policies and procedures that flow
out of this risk and then what you were
doing to try and mitigate the effect
of a disease for where these approaches
of containment have not worked now
my final
boys I do
um and as we've discussed this within
the department I think there is a very
key issue for us about
um
uh the threshold between those two
things so there's been a lot of
discussion of um uh rightly uh of some
of the countries that handle covid
extremely well such as South Korea
effectively what they had was a much
higher threshold of containment for hcid
than we were able to do and that was the
key difference so I do think what we're
talking about points to some of the key
issues about the management of disease
of diseases I don't actually think the
risks were identified
incorrectly and I do think those two
stages or you try and contain a new
disease so that it doesn't lead to a
pandemic and then if it does you try and
mitigate the effect so that the impacts
on society are as small as possible I do
think that is the right thinking I do
think uh in retrospect the questions
about what the thresholds are between
those two things these are very
important thing so Christopher just a
few moments ago you said I quote there
was a flaw in the thinking
um well so in that we have changed our
thinking as I think uh our KC set out in
our opening statement
um at um uh I will continue to
distinguish between what we thought was
reasonable at the time and what we think
now with the light of the experience we
have changed our approach on some of
these issues so it is only fair that I
uh reflect that well
my lady will always ensure that the
process is fair absolutely that was not
the implication that it was not what
um I I choose my words badly
um but um that we have changed our
thinking
um in the light of what we have learned
in the pandemic
um I think I am supposed to say
when that is the case
um and almost by definition
um as we have changed our thinking based
on uh based on our learning
that causes us to ask questions about
our previous approach is that is that is
that a better
way of framing is I wasn't trying to
suggest anything about fairness happily
so crucifer in this process I asked the
question so I I can't answer your
question sorry I'm sorry the uh happily
for you happily for me
Sir Christopher one more question on
this topic
there was you've accepted now a flaw in
the thinking
those three or four pages that Melody
has looked at
show quite clearly that on the one hand
it was well recognized that a
non-influenza pathogen
would be unpredictable
potentially with catastrophic
consequences
that you couldn't say in advance what
the incubation period would be what the
transmissibility would be what the
severity would be that there was a risk
that it would be as
deadly as an influenza pandemic
yes was not that thinking obvious you
say it's now flawed but it was now it's
obvious at the time so let me be let let
me be very clear indeed so the bit
um of this
um where we have
adapted our thinking uh is what I said
earlier uh about uh the piece of
Orthodoxy which was ready for flu ready
for anything
so as I say thinking at the time was you
made a plan for influenza as the most
likely risk and um and uh and still one
of the most dangerous risks and then you
adapted that plan for what was uh in
front of people that is some of the
things it says in the original 2011 uh
version that this would be adapted for
SARS like uh disease now that is
thinking that we have moved on uh from I
don't actually think that the difference
between an hcid sorry a high consequence
infectious disease that you are trying
to contain and a disease that you were
trying to mitigate I don't think that is
uh flawed uh thinking I do think the
question of what's the top of what you
try to contain as opposed to mitigating
that is a clear lesson of the pandemic
and from some other countries that you
correctly quoted in some of your opening
statements about
who we should who we should learn from
one and two the other area well I think
you have your questions
um are right on the um uh right on the
button or on the levels of uncertainty
about the emergencies of uh these
diseases so
um the question is asked were we over
reliant on an influenza plan
um
my view is we were over reliant on plans
period
um we are thinking now is much more in
terms of
what are the flexible capabilities that
allow you uh to
put together the correct type of
response
given the type of disease that happens
to be in front of you as opposed to can
we write a plan for a specific outcome
and then identify it and then second as
has been discussed with a number of your
Witnesses or witty and I'm sure will
come up
um a lot more what is the underlying
resilience
of your system all right I'm going to
interactively just to try to allow us to
well to allow you to draw breath it's a
very very long answer I'm sorry it's
long but
um uh so we have thought about this
quite a lot
um and as you would expect and
um what I'm describing does flow out of
the questions that you are correctly uh
uh correctly asking about these types of
strategies so I do think we'll
um uh your questions are get us to those
questions I don't draw exactly the same
conclusions as you which perhaps I'm
surprising but um I do think we get to
um those sorts of uh uh the sorts of
learning that I have just described all
right so Christopher you made a
reference in the course of that uh
answer uh to the 2011 document yes do I
take it you mean the 2011 United Kingdom
influenza pandemic strategy yes this was
a strategy which was designed was it not
by your department uh yes
and it was a strategy as it says in the
title for dealing with an influenza
pandemic strategy
yes
and as you've rightly acknowledged if I
may say so there was perhaps two greater
dependency upon plans and as we've
discovered to Greater dependency upon an
influenza pandemic plan
was that strategy in 2011 which formed
the basis for this risk assessment
thinking ever updated
um
as in a new one published now
plan to but
um
a pandemic struck before he to Wars was
the plan not published
because of the pandemic
that the work was not finished so the um
so the work was not finished but the
work was in flight at the time now I'm
sick because I'm so sorry
what do you mean the work was in flight
at the time right so we
um I'm
getting confused about the word plan Our
intention
um in uh 2019 was um that we were
working on an update uh of the uh and a
refresh of the influenza plan uh not a
um wholesale uh rewrite there was um uh
not proposals for new strategic thinking
but a refresh of the uh plan those plans
had not finished sorry those are uh that
work had not finished
um at the time that the pandemic broke
out
so Christopher is the answer correctly
to your to my question this
the 2011 document was never updated or
refreshed
and the reason why it was not refreshed
in 2019 was nothing to do with the
pandemic which is what you said a few
moments ago but because your
Department's work was significantly
interfered with by the diversion of
resources to dealing with a No Deal eux
oh yeah yes no and I think we've been
explicit about this that this is one of
the areas of work that we uh that we
paused
um while we were looking very
specifically at the consequences of a No
Deal uh brexit so the work was not in
Flight as you said and the work was not
interrupted by virtue of the pandemic as
you said
um well um it was delayed by the work on
brexit and then the pandemic broke out
it's more specifically sorry I've chosen
my words badly there
did the 2011 strategy
the sole strategy for dealing with a
the detailed plans for a pandemic
pay any regard to overseas experience
from the experience of the other
countries to which you made reference to
a few moments ago who had dealt with
MERS and SARS
um well the um uh the plan makes a
explicit reference to
solos to I think it is
[Music]
correct that in the 2011 plan and in the
substantial uh work that was done post
that we were not looking at the examples
of some of the countries that you
mentioned in your opening statement so
if I may suggest the correct answer is
that whilst there was a reference to
SARS in the 2011 strategy there was no
reference at all to how other countries
had coped with SARS
uh I'm uh there certainly wasn't in the
2011 uh uh plan uh and uh you are
correct that
um uh our plans were um what you might
describe as in the European and Western
mainstream we were not looking at the
examples that uh particularly of uh uh
the um countries you reference and
that's simply a fact but the countries
which had dealt in your own words
perhaps
more efficiently and appropriately with
covid
were the countries that had dealt with
SARS and MERS to which that very risk
assessment makes reference the repeater
references to yeah so why well why was
there no reference or thought given to
experiences of other countries who had
been there before us
um well and
um
I am
in terms of 2011 I am partly
hypothesizing because obviously this was
uh before my time have you read the dog
yes no well as I say I'm quite happy to
comment on Millie uh setting out so
I think this comes into
um the conversation we were having uh
about
um uh the management of high consequence
infectious diseases versus the
management of uh pandemics
so in terms of murals and souls and
including exercise Alice which was for a
high consequence infectious disease we
were looking at those sorts of
containment and elimination
strategies what
um
South Korea and some other countries
very successfully did in
kovid was apply those to much more
widespread diseases land soils and
motors and that was the thing and a
number of people have pointed to this
that we had not built a system to do was
to do that sort of containment
at the sort of scale that
um that they did so as I say the
difference is not
were one set of people thinking about
containment and the other not it was the
scale uh to which they were and I was
like very successful and everyone is
correct uh to point them uh to point to
them on the scale at which uh they were
able to carry that out uh compared to
the much lower scale of containment that
was based in um uh based in our plans
you said earlier and you see in your
witness statement of paragraph 96
the capabilities developed for an
influenza pandemic are often the most
transferable for use in response to
other pandemics should that be required
and the point you made earlier and the
point you make in your statement is well
all right as a country we
we didn't prepare for a coronavirus
pandemic
we had only a generic plan for
emerging infectious disease
it failed to have regard to the likely
or possible characteristics of such a
disease namely that it would be as
devastating as an influenza pandemic but
that's all right the capabilities
developed for an influenza pandemic can
be transferred in use
in response to other pandemics could you
please
itemize shortly list the capabilities
which
can be transferred for use in other
influenza pandemics
there was one before I do
um I don't think it's the case that we
only had a generic plan for high
consequence infectious disease we only
required to have a generic plan by the
national risk register but there was in
fact a extensive program of work led by
the NHS on how you deal with in high
consequence infectious
diseases so I don't think that would
is correct we used quite a lot of the
flu plan in uh in kovid we use the
legislation we use the surge capacity of
the
NHS we use the response function that we
had built up we use the thinking on
public Communications
and the voluntary versions of
non-farmaceutical interventions and
absolutely crucially
um and very successfully we use the
Investments that have been made in
vaccines via the UK vaccine Network
which provided the platform Technologies
uh that turned into the Oxford AZ
vaccines so there were a whole series of
things from the um uh influenza plans
and the workflowing from it that we that
we used they're within some things that
we didn't use as your question
points to
stockpile of personal protective
equipment for an influenza pandemic had
a duration
of about three months
was that a capability which was
transferred to covid or did we run out
um it was undoubtedly transferred in
that we used the pandemic stockpile that
we had built up for influenza in the
early months did the stockpile run out
Christopher we never
um nationally ran out of PPE we were
very short and we had significant
logistical issues
um the um so the stockpile that we had
built up would it be useful in the
pandemic
um
was it big enough for the pandemic that
we had
um it would have been much better were
it to have been larger were the um I
think a lot of Medics would be surprised
at your comment we never nationally ran
out of PPE
um yes and I chose my words very
carefully and um and it's a debate we
have had uh before there were
huge pressures on PPE and we had as I
said significant uh challenges uh
getting PPE to the right place so the
department has never said and it would
not be true to say that in individual
places
um there were shortages of PPE and
people having to use not the right uh
PPE that's different from it having run
out nationally so
um in terms of all the reports people
make of the struggles with PPE and and
the right PPE in an individual place not
being available that was clearly true
so Christopher the stockpile which
existed on the 1st of January 2020 ran
out obviously further PPE had to be
procured but the stockpiled for a
pandemic influenza was not sufficient
was it
um well the was that stockpile
sufficient Sir Christopher
stockpile uh was never intended to cover
uh the whole of the pandemic it was
supposed to create a buffer
um while you ramp up production but
you're the one who said the capabilities
developed for influenza are transferable
for use yeah and the stockpile was
transferred now I did not
um and this was a very deliberate answer
to your question I did not put PPE on my
list of things that we uh transferred
while the stockpile we had was useful
um and um uh prevented us from running
out of PPE at various points
um there was a clear difference between
the PPE we needed for this type of
pandemic and the one we had built up
which is why I didn't put it on my list
of transferables the antiviral
medicine Tamiflu was a capability
developed for influenza pandemic was
that of any use at all in a
non-influenza pandemic no and again that
is why I didn't put it on my list was
that no sorry for Christmas can I just
say some things I believe that you've
answered the question
you'll have an opportunity in a moment
no doubt of answering other questions on
this I'm sorry
in relation to contact tracing on a mass
level or of quarantining or of lockdowns
or any of the more severe social
restrictions
but those capabilities that were
designed in relation to an influenza
pandemic
um so wide Spike scale contact tracing
was never part of the uh the influenza
plan
and lockdowns as in legal lockdowns they
were not what we had planned for
up exercise Alice to which you've
referred so just before you go on was
there anything else you wanted to add
earlier just on antivirals
um at um I mean obviously you would only
stockpile antivirals that exist uh for
diseases uh that you uh know about so in
that case
um I would absolutely defend stockpiling
uh where you do have antivirals that are
relevant uh to a disease uh or you can't
stop particles or say is an antiviral
that doesn't exist so there were no
antivirals for Coronavirus just like
there was no vaccine so the choice to
stockpile it never never arose I don't
think that should I don't think we
should take the lesson but we should
therefore not stockpile antivirals that
we can use will we need to have a flu
epidemic what's my point circus with
respect has anybody suggested that we
shouldn't stop pile antivirals the
question two was because you said there
are capabilities for pandemic influenza
that may be readily transferred to a
non-influenza I was asking you about
what capabilities
I'm sorry if I misunderstood
exercise Alex exercise Alice
there were a number of recommendations
made in the exercise Alice report and in
light of the time I'm not going to take
you through them but lessons or actions
five seven eight and nine
we're concerned with producing a
briefing paper on the South Korea MERS
outbreak
to consider the policy relating to Port
of Entry screening
Action 7 produce an options plan using
extant evidence and cost benefits for
quarantine
on a mass scale
action 8 Community sampling
action 9 develop a live tool or system
to collect data from Mars Co ronavirus
contacts
I appreciate this is a very broad
question but
can you say in general terms whether or
not any of those actions were actually
pursued by your department
following the conclusion of exercise
Alice uh yeah some of them were
partially but we were correct that not
all of them were
completely I should say that was of
course a test of our hcid
mechanisms and not our pandemic
mechanisms
you referred to the experience of Asian
countries
in a Lessons Learned report after the
pandemic in September 2020 do you agree
that your own Department stated that it
would have benefited from a fuller
understanding of the response by Asian
countries which might have enabled us to
start building testing systems earlier
in January 2020. uh yes
could we please have up 57430
this is a memo dated the 27th of March
2019 to Professor sir Chris Whitty the
chief Scientific Advisor
from your department or the dhsc
headed pan flu preparedness and high
consequence infectious disease policy
if you look at paragraphs one and two
and three
they say this you are aware that
following reorganization and
reprioritization of dhsc work due to EU
exit No Deal planning
pan flu preparedness and high
consequence infectious disease policy
has moved to your portfolio
responsibilities on a temporary basis
and then there's a reference to
corporate memory in paragraph two and
and then in paragraph three Emma Reed
and Clara Swinson agreed a range of work
related to pan flu and high consequence
infectious disease that would be scaled
back or paused before this policy error
transferred across to you and then may
we have please page three
this is an Annex Annex a pan flu
preparedness and hcid policy area of
work continuing slowing or pausing as a
result of eux hit prioritization
so Christopher would you cast your eye
please down the left hand side of that
document the column work area
and broadly identify how many areas were
either stopped reduced or paused
just broadly quite a lot
in your statement at paragraph 416 could
we have please one eight four six four
three
one eight four six four three page 79
while it is a matter of judgment the
Department's view is that the United
Kingdom was better prepared for health
related emergencies as a result of the
work conducted on EU exit for example on
Supply the department had a far deeper
understanding of Global Medical Supply
chains and stronger relationships with
industry heightened
stockpiles of critical medicines and
medicinal products would provide an
increased buffer and an improved
emergency response function including
provision for emergency Logistics to
mitigate disruption
so there's a reference there to supply
chains and emergency response function
do you agree that that sentence those
sentences and that paragraph
could go back please
to the phrase UK was better prepared for
health-related emergencies is a proper
and correct reflection of that Annex and
the number
sheer number of work streams for
pandemic planning that were paused or
stopped uh yes now
um as I make clear in my statement uh
this is entirely a matter of judgment I
could not
arithmetically uh arithmetically prove
however
um
what we essentially happened and I
should say
this was not
um there was no this was not a plan or
strategy I'm merely trying to assess
what happened
we stopped a whole load of work which
was about enhancing the flu plan and
taking forward chunks of the flu plan
and we and that's clearly a negative I'm
not trying to imply that that is not a
negative and we added
um a whole series of generic
capabilities that we then used in the
covid covet response
and my reflection on that is that the
capabilities that we build up
um as a byproduct of air No Deal brexit
work were extremely valuable to us uh in
the pandemic so as I say and just to be
very clear I am not trying to suggest
that
um reducing
um uh the work that you showed earlier
in some way enhance does it clearly
didn't it clearly in an Ideal World if
you had all the resources you want you
would do both I am simply saying well
the balance of weighing up those
capabilities that I uh quote in my
witness statement turned out to be in my
judgment more valuable than more work on
the influenza plan
do you agree that the cygnus report
exercise cygnus report concluded that
the United Kingdom's preparedness and
response in terms of its plans policies
and capability were not sufficient to
cope with the extreme demands of a
severe pandemic uh yes that is what it
uh found and as I said earlier there was
then a uh a program of work that
followed
you must have been very concerned when
you read the sickness report and this
conclusion to paragraph six that the
preparedness response both in terms of
plans and policies and capability were
not sufficient to cope
um
I thought cygnus had done its job
properly were you concerned
um uh yes and um and this was an area
where
um I took uh specific
meetings and reports in the uh in the
follow-up we're getting in uh Leeds 2017
which I uh haven't done for a similar
subjects so
but many of the work streams which you
put into place a result of cygnus were
not ultimately actions as we've just
seen because of the competing demands of
operation yellowhammer the plans for a
new deal exit and many of the work
streams were never finished
or only partially completed with it yeah
no I mean that that that is correct
um I think a lot of progress was made
after operation uh signals but you are
completely correct those not all actions
were uh uh completed and that we changed
uh our departmental priorities uh um at
the point that it says
so where between 2018 when operation
yellowhammer was first conceived the
planning for EU exit no deal and the end
of 2019
when it became apparent there would be
no no deal exit do you express your
continuing concerns
that the work streams to make the United
Kingdom compliant with that core
recommendation from exercise cygnus were
not being completed or had been stopped
and that our country system for
preparedness and response was imperiled
sorry I'm not quite sure I understood
the question did you express in a way
that mattered your continuing concern
that the outcome of exercise cygnus was
not being addressed because the work
streams designed to address it were
being interrupted or had been stopped
altogether
um well they they were decisions that
were not taken lightly uh at all
um and Our intention all along was uh
once we had come out of
um at the uh period when we had to plan
for EU exit uh that those things uh
would uh continue I couldn't point you
to a thing I wrote uh on that subject
but that was our expectation exercise
cygnus was a multi-phase exercise a tier
one exercise was it not yes it took
place over two days it was preceded by
another exercise exercise Signet it
involved more than 950 people it was a
serious test of United Kingdom's
response capacity and it largely failed
did it not uh no I don't think that's
the outcome Sir Christopher in paragraph
six
was that our systems plans policies and
capabilities were not sufficient to cope
with a severe pandemic uh well the
country failed that test the uh the
point
of uh exercising is to identify where
your plans are already strong and where
they need enhancing and they were not
strong because the cygnus report was to
the fact that whether in terms of
policies or capability the system was
not sufficient and there was work to do
on the system yes and that one and the
purpose of the exercise uh is to
identify those the preparedness and
response of the United Kingdom was not
sufficient so Christopher do you agree
oh well I mean that is what the report
says yes so over the subsequent three
years the work streams that were put in
place to deal with sickness and that
conclusion about the systemic lack of
capacity preparedness and response
within themselves paused interrupted or
stopped
where is your expression of concern that
we were therefore by the end of 2019
in largely no better a position than we
had been in
2016 October
um well I don't think that is correct
because the number of work streams uh D
to go forward and as I said earlier I
couldn't point you to a piece of paper
that I wrote expressing those concerns
work streams continued in relation to
the ability to deal with just the fact
of excess deaths and the sheer number of
deaths that might be anticipated correct
well that was one of the work streams
work stream continued in relation to how
a severe pandemic might impact on
prisons
yes work continued on how
the health sector the NHS would cope
with the surge demand of a severe
pandemic
yes
but in every other regard whether it was
to do with
the adult social care sector
to do with public health measures to do
with a central repository of information
for how to deal with the severe pandemic
for dealing with the loss of
institutional memory for dealing with
the plans relating to dealing with a
pandemic that list in Annex a no further
work was done in the main by December of
2019. between between the point that we
paused it and that date yes a number of
actions before that date had taken place
so if you take the example of um social
care the follow-up in terms of further
discussions and seminars with local
authorities that my colleagues at mhclg
carried out took place as did the
commissioning of guidance from the
association of directors of Social
Services for the social care sector
which was created and published in 2018
so it is not uh correct that nothing was
taken forward between 2016 and 2020 it
is correct as your exhibit
correctly identifies that a number of
things were paused in mid-2018 for the
reasons that we have set out
by June of 2020
your department reported after the
pandemic that 14 lessons of the 22
recommendations had not been completed
is that correct yes that's correct 14 of
22 not been completed a large number of
those were ongoing yes they had not been
completed by the time six months before
the pandemic had struck had they that's
correct and in relation to social care
policy implications one of the
objectives of exercise Sigma subjective
five
was to develop plans for the social care
facilities to be used to support clients
who were discharged from hospital as
part of the health sector's surge
capacity and whilst there were meetings
held in relation to that important work
stream that was one of the work streams
that was not completed was it no that
wasn't completed no sorry that was not
completed no
in relation to another recommendation
that adult social care should be better
integrated into all aspects of the
dhsc's emergency response system was
that completed uh it wasn't completed
although work was done on that subject
as I have just the meetings were held
were they not well and guidance uh
produced uh by the Association of
directors of social laws of the system
for adult social care better integrated
into the Department's emergency response
um
well in the light of uh what happened in
the uh pandemic I couldn't handle and
hold say uh yes uh there was as I've
described a program of work uh post
cygnus but uh I think he's well known
this is one of the areas where we
adapted our approach most during the
pandemic and we were most challenged in
how we uh dealt with that sector so I
think I couldn't I I couldn't say
um in the light of what happened that
had been successful
I think you've accepted and a number of
bodies have said this in the clearest
terms including care England that some
social care providers did run out of PPE
do you agree uh yes and as I was
describing uh earlier that
um we had two levels of challenge one
was the national Supply where it was uh
exceptionally tight
um but at no point did we actually run
out and two was the logistics of
delivering uh to a much larger uh number
of settings than we had anticipated
which was a huge uh huge struggle as
your Witnesses have
pointed to your own departmental
conclusion was in December 2020 the
covid pandemic has shown that the
clinical countermeasures including PB
held from the influenza pandemic had
limited applicability to non-influenza
pandemic threats is that a way of saying
that
the PPE held for influenza pandemic was
of little assistance to the coronavirus
now it was of um uh it was of assistance
uh what it was not designed uh for and I
know you've discussed this with uh other
Witnesses
was for a disease with a significant
amount of asymptomatic transmission
which required us to provide PPE into a
lot more settings than had been planned
for so yes I recognize that conclusion
nerve tag the committee for new and
emerging respiratory viral threats
Advisory Group
you say in your own statement the
seventh statement of paragraph 76
recommended to the dhsc that surgical
gowns be stockpiled and they did so in
advance of the pandemic were surgical
gowns stockpiled uh the uh the process
of uh
scoping the procurement was underway at
the point when the pandemic broke out so
that had been accepted but the
procurement was not complete at time
that the pandemic uh broke out
in relation to the just in case
contracts which the department had been
involved in or had arranged
and which of course was a basis of the
one of the work streams post-exercise
cygnus did the adjusting case provision
of stockpiles and supplies
meet the demands in January
2020.00 and I think you um referenced
the report those contracts uh didn't
work largely because uh other countries
introduced bans on the exports of uh PPE
and we were there for one I'm sure we
will cover this in much more detail in
other modules forced to go to the
General Market at considerable expense
did your own departmental briefing paper
for oversight and Assurance in July 2020
report that the respirators which have
been provided for frequently fitted
white faces but the ones were better off
which were better off for black staff
were purchased in much smaller quantity
and there had been no provision for that
in the post-exercise cygnus pre-pandemic
planning oh yeah that is a finding that
an apartment found during the uh
pandemic and acted on during the
pandemic that is correct
interrupt but um I was asked to break it
about half faster 25-2 that's a
convenient moment thank you very much
I shall return at five to four
thank you
Sir Christopher
it appears to be common ground
that in so far as your department
considered
when planning for a pandemic
the potential impact on protected groups
as the minorities
vulnerable sectors of society
the marginalized
the position was that
plainly
a pandemic would have different impacts
but that those impacts would be of a
clinical nature
so a pandemic would affect those who
have heart disease or diabetes or
some other comorbidity in a different
way to a healthier member of the
population is that correct uh yes at um
so
when we've
looked at what we did on
uh equalities beyond what we did for
legal compliance uh the focus was
exactly as uh he was uh it was on um uh
the uh the clinical elements of uh uh
inequality and how those would be
impacted by a disease that is correct
and it follows does it not
that neither your department nor in fact
any pre-covered exercise considered the
issue of how
a pandemic in reality or as part of a
test would impact vulnerable people or
those with health inequalities or
related factors other than insofar as
they may be impacted clinically
um yes there is obviously a very large
overlap between the two as us from other
Witnesses
um there was a
there was a lot of thinking in
department and still is about
the issues that you point to
um they were as you say
um
not thought of uh directly in the
context of pandemic preparation so there
was a lot of work on those areas but I
couldn't point you to uh specific parts
of pandemic preparation but you said
there was a lot of thinking in the
department and still is about the issues
that you point to there was no thinking
was there in the department or as part
of any single exercise
between 2007 and 2018 exercise pika
about the impact of plans or the
pandemic or the response of the pandemic
plan for or tested
on vulnerable people
ethnic minorities
or any sector of the population other
than so far as they may be affected
clinically is that correct in the
exercise program yes I think that is
correct
so it's not right to say there was a lot
of thinking about these issues then
there was no thinking about it oh sorry
um
not not explaining myself correctly
in wider Health policy
there is a lot of thinking about health
disparities was my point what uh as I
said what there wasn't was that
specifically in uh pandemic preparation
so ladies inquiry is not into Healthcare
it is into the planning for pandemics
hey yeah that's why I I as I say I chose
my words badly I apologize
and it follows also doesn't it that at
no time did the department ever obtain
specialist advice on health inequalities
and the implications of Health
inequalities on pandemic planning
impacts and mitigation strategies uh no
I don't think we uh ever commissioned
advice on that until actually during the
pandemic when of course we did a lot
a bit late so Christopher I'm sorry I'm
not um I'm merely setting out
uh
I'm sorry I'm nearly setting out all
happened I'm no further questions thank
you would my lady give me one Moon
melody in relation to
the rule 10 process
I believe the whilst a number of
questions were posed by
One Core participant you have not
provisionally indicator that anything
any of them should be posed
and therefore in light of that
provisional education
now that we've actually heard Sir
Christopher are you minded to confirm
your provisional indication and not
allow any further questions to be asked
is there any furthest emissions yes sir
thank you very much
may I ask um roughly how many staff did
you have to allocate to operation
yellowhammer and the brexit No Deal I
believe in total
um we we allocated in the process we
were talking about earlier approximately
70 I will have to go and confirm that
but I think it was about 70.
um the that happened across government
departments everyone was told you've got
to provide a number of Staff well no
this was the this was the internal
re-prioritization going on within so
this is the DH this is not the general
response to a No Deal brexit this is the
Health Department's response yeah so we
we had a number of work streams of which
we were responsible by by Miles the
biggest of which and our biggest worry
uh was about the supply of uh
Pharmaceuticals uh during the uh uh
during and no deal brexit and
particularly the number that came
through um uh the uh the short straights
so we owned a number of work streams and
when Elohim was also out on my statement
became the principal focus of government
uh
departments reprioritized within there
was also a re-prioritized across uh
government as a whole but the one here
which affected our pandemic preparations
was the internal dhsc uh exercise if
that's clear thank you you said that as
a result of the pandemic they're things
that you would have done differently
with the benefit of hindsight and
whatever other element of judgment you
may want to use can you give some
practical
examples of what you would have done
differently you'd never know so
um obviously the uh um uh the report
done by the chief medical office and the
government Chief Scientific Advisor
gives a uh uh a very comprehensive uh
list of uh the learnings from the
pandemic when we discussed this uh
within the department it comes down to
um uh I've uh uh five things
um the two biggest ones I've uh
mentioned uh already which is
the focus on capabilities and underlying
resilience as opposed to plans and
systems
third is
um
what's become known as the
pathogen agnostic approach to planning
which is moving away from the ready flu
ready for anything philosophy I was
describing earlier
towards a uh let's look at the roots of
transmission
that's the third one the fourth is a
focus on
surge capacity which was clearly a big
problem for us at the beginning of the
uh pandemic getting from the initial
response phase so that when you've
deployed the full
[Music]
armaments of the state focusing on that
phase and fifth as I think has been
widely reported and I think Governor
voice was science also made this point
we were short of testing we did not have
the testing capacity that some of our
European or other counterparts had so in
terms of how we're thinking about
pandemic preparation going forward
compared to what I have described it's
those five areas which we see as the uh
as the biggest ones
um that's obviously not an exhaustive
list
and and it's not a complete at least
in that of course the government will um
uh when it's set up this inquiry because
he wishes to get to listen to that and
so we're not trying to finalize what we
think but in terms of where our thinking
is it is those five areas that we think
would make the biggest
uh differences in our approach to
planning
thank you that's all I ask
thank you very much indeed to
Christopher so you've been so long
yes but my lady the next witness is
Clara Swinson who I understand is in the
process of being brought into the
witness box
oh
[Applause]
thank you Miss Swenson would you like to
take the oath please
[Music]
sincerely and truly declared declare and
affirmative
that the evidence I shall give shall be
the truth shall be the truth the whole
truth
and nothing but the truth
I'm sorry you've been waiting for most
of the day
will you give your full name to the
inquiry please Yes Clara Jane Swinson
thank you
um
please keep your voice up and speak into
the microphones I can see that you're
adjusting them thank you very much so
that the stenographer can can hear you
for the transcript and if I
um I'm not clear in my questioning um
please by all means ask me to repeat it
um
first of all
um Miss Swinson may we have on the
screen please
um both of your witness statements
firstly inq triple zero one eight two
six zero eight and can you confirm
please that that is your first witness
statement correct it's true to the best
of your knowledge and belief it is may
we have permission to publish that
please my lady and secondly inq treble
zero two one two three one four
thank you it is that your second witness
statement it is and again is it true to
the best of your knowledge and belief it
is yes thank you we can take that down
I'm going to begin by setting up briefly
an overview of your career history as
it's relevant to inquiry you've been a
senior civil servant since 2006. you are
director General within the Department
of Health and Social care covering
International health and domestic public
health issues and you've held that role
since November 2016. yes since this
appointment
um you have reported to the permanent
secretary Sir Christopher wormald he's
just given evidence yes and you are a
member of the dhsc executive committee
and a senior sponsor for UK HSA formerly
phe that's right thank you you are
responsible for three directorates
including the directorate on emergency
preparation and health protection to
which we'll turn in a moment yes your
chair of the pipp or pip board now newly
renamed the pandemic preparedness
portfolio board and you've been
perhaps we'll come to that my lady
and you've been chair of the pit board
since 2017 and until it was reformed as
the uh under its new name in 2022 you
were also responsible for preparations
for the EU exit
that's right and if I could just add I'm
responsible for more than three direct
threats that you said at the start my
responsibilities have changed a little
bit uh since 2016 uh for exactly but
that is set out in my witness statement
all right thank you very much uh you're
responsible for international policy
bilateral relationships and health work
on a multilateral basis correct for
example at the World Health Organization
G7 Summit Etc and finally you are a UK
senior official on the global Health
security Action Group I am thank you
um I want first of all please Mrs
Swinson to deal with emergency
preparedness and health directorate and
the EP RR function
um
the directorate has day-to-day
responsibility for pandemic preparedness
doesn't it that's right among other
things right and what specifically does
that entail in terms of emergency
planning
pandemic preparedness yes within the
within the directorate yes so that
requires
um
oversight of the Health and Care System
responsibilities so across the
department NHS England and public health
England as was UK Health Security Agency
now it
um means repair preparing for any
exercises there are it also means with
emergency planning being responsible for
plans for non-pandemic threats yes that
might be biological or they might be
chemical they might be terrorist attacks
or so on all right
um it exists to respond then to a wide
range of emergencies including pandemic
and infectious disease outbreaks but
isn't limited to that as you've just
explained yes
um is its role to support an emergency
response
it would depend slightly on what the
incident was so we would stand up an
instant team that could be anything from
you know a major Cyber attack it could
be the Manchester Arena attack so it
could be something that was Health
specific and it would depend exactly
whose responsibilities
um or whether for so on but it is for
whatever the impact is on the Health and
Care System it is to coordinate and
oversee the response of the system all
right and were you confident that the
Epi of our function to be stood up in
response to the risk from a pandemic
would be sufficient to meet the risk of
a significant pandemic whilst you were
in that role
um
so the function itself
um I've set out in terms of this in a
response phase yes it would need to be
scaled according uh to the
um the incident right so that could be
something that a small team could do it
could be something that we would need to
expand but but do does the um does the
directorate and and does um does the
organization have within it the the
capacity to upscale in the event of a
large emergency yes that would require
resources across the department uh it
has happened in the in the covid-19
pandemic right
um in terms of the pandemic preparedness
program
um I want to ask you some questions
about the UK influenza pandemic strategy
of 2011.
um
brought into Force um following the Hein
review and the recommendations within
Dame Deirdre Heinz report and largely
um untouched until the coronavirus
pandemic hit because isn't it right Miss
Swinson that the coronavirus action plan
published in March 2020 Drew very
heavily on the 2011 strategy it is
correct yes
um Isabel Oliver the interim Chief
scientific officer at the ukhsa
um has confirmed and this inquiry has
already heard quite a lot of evidence
even so far about this that the only
pandemic scale plan in place at the time
that covid hit was the one set out in
the strategy that was for pandemic
influenza
do you agree with that the only plan in
place did you say yes the only plan in
place the only strategy to be followed
and the only the only plan that was in
place was UK wide obviously some other
organizations had their own plans but
yes uk-wide it was the 2011 strategy was
still existing right do you think
um knowing what you do now that there
was good reason for that plan to have
been updated between 2011 and when the
pandemic hit
um so there were reasons to update it
for example
um it was before the 2012 act to be
clear about roles and responsibilities
and so on in terms of its overall
um approach in terms of the principles
the main areas there would have been
some things that were worth updating
refreshing such as what
um
uh so for example you know technology
had changed uh since 20 at 11 vaccine
manufacturing and so on but the basic
premise of the plan there was not a
different strategy that um we were
that was in place that we needed to
publish the basic premise of the
principles is as set out in the 2011
plan what about the fact that it is only
dealt with pandemic influenza what do
you say about that yes
um
I mean that is it flows from the
national register that you've been
talking about today
um we have reflected in the new pandemic
portfolio that you referred to in the
opening is a recognition that now we are
doing that we are we would like the
strategy to be along uh all of the
different routes of transmission not
just a respiratory uh pandemic so was
that a mistake for it only to be limited
to that do you think in hindsight and
knowing what happened in the intervening
period especially with other
coronaviruses across the world but
perhaps that should have been drafted
more widely I think it was a reasonable
um decision at the time I think it was
in line with expert advice and that was
not
um a response to it saying it should
have been extended but clearly at
knowing what we do now as set out we are
changing our approach to cover all the
routes of transmission all right I'd
like to look please at the witness
statement of Professor Mark woolhouse at
inq000182616
thank you very much paragraph 10 which
is on the previous page I think
thank you
um
in the event our go-to response to
covid-19 which became lockdown of itself
that highlights a striking deficiency in
the UK's pandemic preparedness we had no
plans to implement lockdown at all on
the contrary and here's the point the
UK's 2011 pandemic influenza strategy
document States during a pandemic the
government will encourage those who are
well to carry on with their normal daily
lives for as long and as far as that is
possible whilst taking basic precautions
to protect themselves from infection and
lessen the risk of spreading influenza
to others the UK government does not
plan to close borders stop Mass
Gatherings or impose controls on public
transport during any pandemic lockdown
was an ad hoc Public Health intervention
contrived in real time in the face of a
fast-moving Public Health Emergency we
had not planned to introduce lockdown
and this has two serious consequences
which he goes on to deal with
it's right isn't it Miss Swinson that
the 2011 strategy did not include any
plans for mitigation measures such as
Lockdown closing borders stopping Mass
Gatherings or controls on public
transport
um it's true what it says here and
elsewhere in the document it says it's
the working assumption that there
wouldn't be
um restrictions on some of the things
you've mentioned it does say that there
might be restrictions on some Mass
events and some school closures but the
working assumption is as set out yes
other than mentioning those matters
which you've just set out and there are
no plans to to mitigate there there's no
discussion about the potential outcome
of for instance controlling Mass
Gatherings or closing schools is there
um
there are a range of things to mitigate
when one doesn't have medicines or
treatments so there's advice to people
if they're unwell for example to stay at
home through to some of the more Extreme
Measures that um you've just mentioned
but yes that is what is set out in the
strategy all right but but there's no
discussion of the impact of the
imposition of those sorts of
restrictions there is no discussion of
Legally enforced at stay at home no and
what Professor Mark woolhouse goes on to
say is
um the lack of such measures is a
striking deficiency in the UK's pandemic
preparedness do you agree with him
I'm not aware of any
um country that had a lockdown plan
obviously
um
it's what happened in the pandemic and
we both in the department and across
Society need to reflect on that but it
was not something that uh was in the UK
plan or any other country that I'm aware
of nor discussion of any of the other
measures which we've which we've set out
other than Mass Gatherings and school
closures that there's no discussion
about any of the other mitigating
in positions in terms of social
distancing yes in terms of closing
borders in terms of controls of public
transport that sort of thing and what
Mark woolhouse is saying is the lack of
that sort of information in the strategy
is a striking deficiency the question to
you is do you agree with that
um
a strategy did not have those things in
it I think that was reasonable at the
time it was not something that there was
a consultation on this document for
example uh clearly as the pandemic
occurred uh actions that were taken in
other countries and then in the UK it
did lead to Legal restrictions on daily
life do you agree that the 2011 strategy
also didn't plan for a whole system
effect with wide-ranging impacts on
society the economy public services that
sort of thing well I believe it has a
section
um on the whole system of fact the fact
that it would affect the whole of
society it would have societal and
economic
um impacts is set out in the strategy
um thank you we can take that down
Jeremy Hunt in his statement to the
inquiry has said
um I believe with the benefit of
hindsight that our preparations were
affected by an element of group think
and by that I mean that the spread of
many distinct types of virus could
create a pandemic yet our shared belief
was that the most likely scenario was a
pandemic flu what do you say about that
um
so it's true that our expert advice was
that pandemic flu uh was and actually
continues to be the biggest risk
um you've taught that some detail today
about the range of other pandemics yeah
I've explained
um how learning what um from what
happened that we should take that was
setting out a different approach
um I think a number of witnesses experts
have also set out in their statements
for you that they think flu was a
reasonable scenario but clearly there
was not different expert advice before
the pandemic expert advice and our
experience would now show that we should
plan for a wider amount of a wider group
of viruses
do you think there is a need for more
robust Challenge and diverse expertise
or perspectives in terms of what may
happen so in terms of expert advice and
group think yes there are um you know a
whole range of advisory groups which
we've set out in our witness statements
yes you've got evidence from the chairs
of some of those
um both in terms of expertise in the UK
our chief scientific advisors and in
terms of learning from other countries
um you know I don't think it was group
thinking a very small number of people I
think that is the case across the UK and
for most of our European and American uh
colleagues or um counterparts clearly as
Jeremy Hunt stepped out learnings
particularly from Southeast Asia and
maybe expanding the expert
um input from what we've learned now and
showed that there were some other ways
of thinking about containment of a new
novel disease and how to respond to it
that that on that point alone that could
have been done couldn't it at some point
past 2016 when it was recommended from
the um Fallout of exercise Alice that
that South Korea for instance should
have been contacted and and the way in
which that they responded to MERS could
be analyzed and the UK could take from
that
um in indications of how best to for
them to react in a similar position but
that that wasn't done
I don't know whether I'd be surprised if
there was no contact between Public
Health experts in this country and South
Korea at on MERS for example in terms of
the learning at the very extensive
contact tracing and yes uh so on that
did not lead to a change in policy in
this country all right and and are you
aware of the analysis of contact tracing
and precision lockdown and that sort of
thing being carried out
I'm not no no
um I'd like to turn now to the pandemic
influenza preparedness program otherwise
known as pit
bearing on the the
um the chairs question why has that now
been renamed the pandemic preparedness
portfolio board uh so that it's uh
covers in scope
um all the routes of transmission
um not just respiratory viruses and
within that not just influenza
I'm still a question whether it was
necessary to change the name but that
that's probably for another time this
was the eyes stood for an influenza so
um I needed to be friends that needed to
be removed yeah right
um in any event pip was the central
dhsc-led program involving involved in
organizing directing and managing
pandemic preparedness amongst the dhsc
and other bodies and it worked together
with public health England and NHS
England is that correct that's right in
my witness statements I set out 12 areas
in the court for statement of pandemic
preparedness but pip is one very
important one of those all right thank
you
um and it was in operation from October
2007 until July 2022.
um in terms of
the work of pip was it initially shaped
by the approach set out in the influence
UK influenza strategy or certainly since
2011. since 2011 yes yeah and
um you've been kind enough to provide to
us a series of minutes from the pit
board meetings
um
in July of 2017
we can see that a series of five work
streams were set out during the course
of that meeting I don't think we need to
to look at the the meeting notes
themselves but you'll be familiar with
the Miss Winson and can you confirm that
the first four work streams were as
follows Serge and triage
Community Care
excess deaths and sector resilience and
that those four work streams were
themselves derived from the findings of
exercise sickness
I can they were work streams of the uh
cabinet office the HSC joint board the
pandemic flu Readiness board
um and uh so some of those were not
purely about the Health and Care System
yes but the Health and Care System
aspects uh yes were taken across and and
formed into the work streams thank you
can we look please at a paper prepared
for a pip meeting regarding exercises in
October 2018 it's that inq double zero
double zero two three zero one seven
thank you very much
we can see
um page one and sets out that this is an
exercising paper and the first paragraph
deals with background and I want to
focus in please on the next paragraph
which is headed principles
to supporting the development of future
pandemic flu exercises and assist in the
prioritization of areas to exercise this
paper proposes the following principles
number one exercises should be
coordinated across dhsc nhse and phe to
prevent duplication number two exercises
should test existing plans and
strategies rather than known gaps in
knowledge
number three there should be a regular
program of tier one exercises to
coincide with each new Parliament and
ensure continuity and preparation and
preparedness number four where possible
exercises should include devolved
Administration colleagues to ensure a
joined up approach across the four
nations including an observer roles
where active participation is not
appropriate and Five Lessons Learned
should be shared with other relevant
government departments to ensure
continued cross-government approach to
pandemic flu preparedness
now I'd just like to return to number
two exercises should test existing plans
and strategies rather than known gaps in
knowledge
so it
right that
the exercises following on from this
meeting in October 2018 were only to
test existing plans rather than than
gaps in knowledge
yes in terms of the exercise program
okay how then did pip examine it to
known unknowns how did it deal with with
matters that weren't known at all or
were barely known about if as this
principle suggests the exercises should
only test existing plans and strategies
yes so
pip did exactly as you say and that was
in response to the
government strategy the learnings from
cygnus there are other elements of our
um pandemic preparedness for example our
research base or our clinical
countermeasures which could go wider but
um
there was not in terms of a com there
was not work to completely re-look at
the plan or strategy
it was not something that
um our expert advice said in terms of
going wider than flu for example and so
in terms of the work we were doing that
was to test existing plans should there
have been in your opinion should there
have been wider work done on the
unknowns or the barely knowns
um the unknowns in terms of pandemic
preparedness are very great and they
would be they were they are also set out
in a large section of the 2011 strategy
where there are unknowns that's about
research and development that's about
um having flexible resources it's about
scientific advice all of those things so
it
um there are other elements of the
program
that or the preparedness that would do
that
um but it is fair to say looking back
that we now wish that scope to be wider
thank you
now um
at some point during the life of pip and
it began to create what are known as pip
risk registers
um you've been kind enough to provide to
us the registers for
2016-2017-2018 2020 and 2021. the first
question with Swinson is why did this
system only get going in 2016
um I don't know whether that's the case
it certainly was um from when I took
over the boards chair in 2016
um so I couldn't confirm whether in fact
I I'm pretty sure in fact I know that
those risk registers do include risks
that were closed and go back uh before
2016. so I think they would have existed
in Sunday from at least 2011. all right
thank you and are you able to see why
there appears to be a gap in 2019
a gap of what sorry well we haven't been
provided with the risk register for 2019
there is a there is a two-year gap
between 2018 and 2020. is there a reason
for that so in 2019 there were planned
to be two meetings uh each year
um there was one meeting in 2019 uh one
meeting was uh taken out of the schedule
to allow for resources on operation
yellowhammer as you've uh discussed that
was the EU exit it was apologies the No
Deal uh EU exit uh plans I would have to
check the minutes of that meeting to see
um whether there was a risk register
tabled or not or right but but it sounds
very much as if
um its absence may have had to do with
the operation yellowhammer planning
possibly yes all right
um I'm not going to display the risk
registers they are extremely large
aren't they
they're very wide and they have an
enormous amount of information in them
but but could you please miss Swinson
explain to the chair what
pause
[Laughter]
uh that may have been generated by the
thought of putting the risk registers on
the screen
could you kindly explain to the chair
please what what the purpose of the risk
register is and the sort of information
and that they contained and I will as I
think I've indicated to you and just
take you briefly through
um the on
I'm going to continue okay um the
ongoing risk to Health and Social Care
Systems and use that as an example so
with that in mind and please explain
what they are of course
um so I think they're quite usual
program documentation that would be
recognizable to people working on
programs that would set out the issue at
the impact that would have if it
occurred a risk owner and a rag rating
red Amber green for the uh how
um uh it was in the previous periods and
now and where you're hoping to get to
and what was the purpose of the risk
register who was going to use it once it
was compiled
so it was brought to the regular uh pick
meetings and it set out the um actions I
should have added that needs to be taken
in order to try and improve at the work
against those risks all right thank you
so in 2016
there was a risk identified that the
Health and Social care system may be
unable to cope with an extreme surge in
demand for services in the event of a
pandemic that's right isn't it yes
and are you able to remember without
looking at the the risk register what
sort of action was taken away in order
to try and mitigate that risk
um
not from memory uh no um there was work
obviously arising from cygnus in terms
of NHS surge
um the risk registers would also cover
relatively lower level
um detail from teams in terms of funding
resourcing business cases and so on
right and so once that risk had been
identified and the rating had been given
to it and an action had been raised yes
um what would you expect to have taken
place between the time that that risk
register had been
um drafted and the following year when
the next risk register was drafted in
other words would any action that had
been taken be carried forward to the
next risk register in the following year
uh there should be yes it would depend
ENT priorities across the department I
also note that the risk you at pickup is
a is a very large one that has been
identified you know over many years and
it's not that uh two or three actions
would be able to be taken forward in a
six-month period that would completely
resolve it it would be completely normal
that the risk registereds were
highlighting major issues that were read
or marked March read and would be very
difficult things to change all right
well well I think you know where I'm
going that the same risk is present in
2017 and 2018 and in in 2018 in relation
to this it confirms that the plans on
have not been fully tested and that is
still an issue now
I I'm going to skip over 2019 because we
we as we've established we don't have
the risk register for that year but but
in
um 2020 December 2020
um that risk is still present and that
the Health and Social care system uh may
be unable to cope in the event of a
pandemic
what if at all is the interconnection
between that being raised as one of the
issues in the risk register and the
recommendations that we see in exercise
cygnus that there may be concerns about
surge capacity particularly in Health
and Social care is there a connection
between the two did one formulate the
other or or or what
yes I I think there's a link between the
two I mean I think that risk that
probably existed before the
recommendations of cygnus it's a risk
that I think
um as I say would never be completely
mitigated with full confidence are you
able to say over the period of time
between 2016 and 2020 what actions were
completed in terms of mitigating that
risk the risk being NHS surge yet health
and Health and Social care capacity sure
um so
um
it would be made up of a you know a
whole range of things growing countries
need human turn Aid and protection
coordinated needs assessments
contingency planning and pregnancy
options are both to decrease demand and
they're to increase capacity so for
example in their draft pandemic flu Bill
we've prepared
um powers to have regulatory easements
on the demand side for example from CQC
the regular the quality commission sorry
and to increase capacity so in order to
bring be able to bring back a Workforce
who might have been recently retired or
had hadn't kept up their
um registration so those are two
examples you would need obviously both
on scale and number to have you know a
whole range of things but that's um one
example of the work that we did take
forward on the draft legislation in
terms of surge capacity of Staff
apart from acknowledging that that was
something which would need to happen in
order to mitigate the risk yes were
there any practical Arrangements made as
far as you are aware that were in place
by the time that covert hit relating to
that surge capacity of stuff
so I would say surge is a spec
does every year surge in Winter to open
new Wards for example for parts of the
year
um of course in terms of the overall
funding and capacity of the NHS that was
something that was looked at in exactly
the time period you're talking about in
terms of the spending review the funding
both the workforce and for beds and
capacities so there would have been
things both on the large scale in terms
of overall capacity and as I say
preparations for example on legislation
right well in relation to the progress
of implementing the cygnus
recommendations relating to
um social care could we look at please
inq double zero double zero five seven
five two two
thank you
and can we go to page 14 please
and if we look at um that the entry just
below the midline it's Li 18 a
methodology for assessing social care
capacity and surge capacity during a
pandemic should be developed this work
should be conducted by dclg DH and
directors of adult social services and
with colleagues in the devolved
Administrations
and if we look at the column on the
right hand side we can see it was
identified as a two-year program of work
by the pfrb you want to develop the
policy options and your two to agree
reporting routes a policy paper had been
completed and on Community Care during a
pandemic a draft strategy had been
developed but moving down to the
penultimate paragraph there worked to
develop robust data and operational
relationships with the social care
sector did continue through EU exit
preparedness work despite the pause in
the pfrb program plans to issue guidance
to the adult social care sector are
linked to a wider refresh of the
guidance and strategy documentation for
a future influenza pandemic so it looks
as if work had been done but that the
the whole of the methodology and the
implementation of that was still being
worked upon at the time that the
pandemic struck is that fair that's fair
yes thank you we can take that down now
before we leave operation cygnus
um it's come to the attention of the
inquiry that the report itself from the
exercise was was not published until
very recently
um you're nodding your head you're aware
of that of course are you able to
explain why that report was not
published until fairly recently
Direct
a website for all of the local
resilience for her and wider
that's led by the cabinet office so it
went out widely so sorry to interrupt
but it was nothing unredacted form
um I there might have been uh some names
um with active for example but yes that
was the report uh
that went out in terms of publishing it
so that anyone could access it on a
website that that was not done we also
um I think that is common or was common
across all of the exercises through the
tier one program not just Health
um partly because they're
um the reasons about it being you know
going to the people who most needed to
know I think that is one thing that in
terms of transparency
um in in terms of a forward program and
I think this will be in the minutes of
one of the more recent boards uh from me
that there ought to be uh a presumption
to make these things widely public to a
wider audience thank you
um
I'd like to look please at one of the
orc Lessons Learned reviews it's at inq
double zero double zero eight seven two
two seven
[Applause]
and can we go to page six please and
paragraph 6.4
[Applause]
thank you
um we have identified four specific
areas where respondents indicated that
action would help stand the department
in a stronger position ahead of any
future health emergency and going down
to the second paragraph headed
preparedness of the adult social care
sector we see this some commented that
emergency planning had assumed that care
providers would be responsible for their
own response and a centralized
government role had not been anticipated
initial government expectations stemmed
from the complex and largely private
nature of adult social care in the UK
though contingency plans were in place
and tested some respondents stated that
the pandemic highlighted glaring
emissions in strategic direction of
integration and preparedness meaning
that the social care system was not able
to respond to a major health emergency
Mr Swinson do you accept that there were
glaring emissions in strategic direction
of integration and preparedness which
meant that the social care system could
not respond
uh there was certainly
um I mean this is a report of what
people said from uh the team we were not
self-congratulatory about everything
going well we wanted to learn from wave
one for wave two that is to be commended
it completely reflects that feedback
um of course uh in terms of the of
understanding about
um adult social care data and the
national system that was the legal and
Regulatory system that was set up since
in the 2022 act that there are
additional Powers the government has
taken it was not something that in terms
of data sharing for example
um
in in the legal system that was in place
in 2020
um
it was not a system that was a
nationally directed one social care is
managed through local authorities and
responsibility of aperture local
authorities all right so so do I
summarize your evidence in this way you
you wouldn't use the phrase glaring
emissions but you do accept that those
involved in the system acknowledged here
that there were difficulties in
strategic direction of integration and
preparedness within the system
I think that's uh that's fair and the
social care system not being able to
respond to a major health emergency uh
is obviously you know there are very
many different providers and that would
be varied uh but I think uh how you have
uh um explained it is fair thank you
moving finally then on to clinical
countermeasures in PPE this will of
course form
um part of a future module but I I just
want to ask you some questions please
about your responsibility and
involvement
um in the provision of stockpiles and
for you to explain to us really
um how and public health England managed
stockpiles relating to to pandemics
okay
so um
you've provided
um your
um evidence on
um the review of countermeasures for
pandemic influenza and infectious
diseases now that's a document we don't
need to to put it up and we can take
down the one that's currently on the
screen please but that's a document
which opens with the following the
covid-19 pandemic has shown clinical
countermeasures held from an influenza
pandemic have limited ability
applicability sorry to non-influenza
pandemic threats and that is something
which you would accept and that the PPE
stockpile has been designed with
influenza in mind restricting its
utility for other infectious diseases
Beyond pandemic influenza
what is the current position regarding
stockpiles for hcids
and and and what is the planning in
terms of a future pandemic yes so
um
we are bringing together an assessment
with our deputy chief medical officer
that looks at obviously what was already
in place before the pandemic
um for some things that are still there
for example for flu where stocks have
been used through the covid pandemic and
where there are different stockpiles for
example antibiotics for a whole range of
things and so we are reviewing those
countermeasures and both kind of the
wind down from covid ones we've got
covert treatments antivirals now as well
to say what is the
um what are the counter measures we wish
to keep on an ongoing basis
um
compared to the wider scope of not just
flu but pandemics and indeed on the
points you raise for example on PPE that
is also relevant for chemical or
biological
um non non-pandemics but other high
consequence infectious diseases as
you've mentioned and other major threats
that could be chemical biological radial
nuclear
um
has there been an improvement do you
think in the systems that are now in
place in terms of the provision of PPE
both in in stockpiles and the range of
PPE which which is now being considered
uh yes I think that is fair it is now
managed by the NHS supply chain yes in
terms of countermeasures uh there are
things that are used in day-to-day
um Health and Care and so it is about
having a stock that you can rotate and
use there's another set of things for
how they're stored and how we should
approach them where you would not expect
to use it day to day it is actually an
insurance policy against a threat that
may or may not happen so there's both
what to what to stockpile on Expert
advice uh how to hold it and what is
rotated through normal use in the NHS
thank you
um Professor Banfield of the the BMA has
told the inquiry in his witness
statement at paragraph 33 no need to
display it please that the government's
actions meant that PPE at the time was
not available to suit a diverse range of
facial features including for smaller
often female face shapes and for staff
who wear a beard or hair covering for
religious reasons
do you accept that there is a need to
consider sufficient supplies of PPE to
fit a wide range of face shapes and
sizes and that that wasn't perhaps
adequately considered as part of
pandemic planning prior to covert 19.
yes I do
was that foreseeable and should it have
been done
um
in terms of the assumptions about PPE
um before the pandemic there are a
number of assumptions that turned out
not to be the case it was never the case
that uh
um the Assumption was that it would be
above business as usual volumes
um so it would be an additional
stockpile for people to draw on but that
business as usual that's that stocks
would continue clearly because of the
global demand and in fact uh that
pandemic starting in China and they're
being locked down to this and that's
where a lot of the manufacturing was
that the oval supply chain uh collapsed
so that was one assumption that
behavioral use and the fact that the
other a second assumption that is that
PPE would be used just for symptomatic
patients yes
um actually
um very much more was needed and covered
at 19 as we've set out I think in Chris
work molds
um statement number six or seven
um as it
um it is now you it was used in the
pandemic uh for asymptomat for all
Health and Care and so the volumes were
very very much greater than we had ever
assumed it was one of the problems in in
planning in this way a lack of data that
the reason that I ask you that is
returning to the orc Lessons Learned
review which we've already touched upon
there is a statement in there as follows
there was insufficient data available to
consider equality issues around PPE
provision a retrospective equality
impact assessment is now being
undertaken and will help address these
concerns
I apologies because you asked about
that that is something that definitely
came out in wave one Kevin Fenton from
public health India has carried out a
review it was evident in the first few
months that is something where there
were not enough different types of face
mask and that is something both in
business as usual and in our stock tiles
of course we need to make sure are
covered in future now and in the future
right
thank you very much
um those are all the questions which I
have for Miss Swinson and would you
excuse my back my lady
[Applause]
and um in the usual way I think your my
lady has provided a provisional
um consent for certain questions to be
asked
um and I will turn to miss Monroe King's
Council to ask those questions if my
lady that is appropriate yes
thank you Miss Monroe thank you
thank you
good afternoon Miss Swinton my name is
Alison Monroe and I represent covid bery
families UK
just a few questions in relation to
um World Health Organization research
and development blueprint reports we
don't need to have these brought up but
for reference my lady they are found the
2017 reporters at inq triple zero one
four nine one
zero eight
um and just to contextualize those
reports for you miss Swinton
um the 2017 and the 2018
uh reports Hugh The Who research and
development blueprints as air called
determined that there was an urgent need
for research and development into MERS
and SARS and other highly pathogenic
coronavirus diseases
uh the 2018 blueprint report also
prioritized disease X and both reports
noted the importance of cross-cutting
research and development which would
help to address a range of different
pathogens or diseases at the same time
finally Professor sir Peter hawby of
nerve tag and Dr Miles Carroll of the
phe were members of these prioritization
committees now at the time of their
Publications would you have read those
reports
um I had not read those reports no
you've not read them I have they were in
the 2017 I think was in my witness
bundle uh I'm aware of what it is and
aware of some of the work flowing from
it but I don't think I had read that at
the time
would there any of the information in
those reports have been brought to your
attention at the time
um
so
in terms of the research that the UK
would do that isn't just my job but in
terms of departments and in fact the
foreign Commonwealth office where we
would prioritize research funding that
would definitely be
brought to the government's attention
and indeed the government took some
actions that I think do link back
exactly to the research and development
blueprint
right but in terms of your role and then
the course of your elders director
General in the dhsc how important would
those documents those reports because
they talk about prioritizing in
particular MERS and SARS yes so
um
the chief Scientific Advisor in the
department is the DG level responsible
for our research and development at
think these are very important documents
for all countries because they list the
diseases where there could be a major
public health International Event and
where there was not a pipeline or
incentives on industry currently to
um have to develop
um
uh vaccines Therapeutics or Diagnostics
um so that would have been a um I'm sure
um within our chief Scientific Advisor
and our foreign office uh Chris Whitty
uh through the uh chair of the UK
vaccine Network for example had a
prioritized a list which was not
identical to the who1 but had
similarities for uh where to invest at
Research into vaccines
from those answers I am I to gather them
but in terms of the work and strategies
of your own Department
um
a prioritization in terms of research
and development of Mayors and SARS and
disease X would not be something that
you would have done or prioritize no I I
don't think that's correct
um the UK vaccine Network prioritized
um a vaccine into MERS that became at
the Oxford AZ platform I think most of
the research would be funded by overseas
development assistant money order money
and that is uh
that there is some in the department of
health and also in the foreign and
Commonwealth development office I'm more
thinking at the time of their
publication though 2017 yeah and 2018
in terms of research and development and
particularly this question of
prioritizing those air those diseases
was that part of the strategy of your
department at all it was in terms of
prioritizing research and development uh
where there were very substantial
budgets across governments both in the
department of health and in the foreign
and Commonwealth office and diffid yes
that would have been taken into account
right the these reports um also agreed
on the value where possible of
developing countermeasures for multiple
diseases or for families of pathogens
um what if any action did your
department take in relation to this and
how was that monitored
um so I've given one example which is
the research and development funding
that went uh to Oxford that on the MERS
vaccine we would have to look further
for others as I say that will be through
our chief Scientific Advisor
both in the department and the network
across government
um can you assist on this please what if
any action uh was there taken to update
the UK's list of high consequent
infectious diseases to include disease X
or highly pathogenic coronavirus disease
is following those reports in 2017 and
2018.
so that high consequence infectious
disease list is kept under review by
um groups or the chief medical officer
the medical director of the NHS and the
advisory committee on dangerous
pathogens it's not a static list it does
change it is pathogens that actually
exist and there's quite a long list
disease X as you have put in your
question is the idea of a of a novel
pathogen that would divide arise clearly
you need to do research into a whole
have flexible Reserve research in order
to be able to respond to a pathogen that
doesn't yet exist
in terms of the findings from those two
reports from 2017 and 2018.
um to what extent were they considered
or reflected in the National risk
assessment
in particular again going back to this
point about the prioritization of SARS
and MERS yes so for high cons for the
high consequence infectious diseases the
risk that you were discussing earlier on
an emerging infectious disease
um obviously was based uh um or the
scenario was a um a SARS or MERS type of
coronavirus in terms of other threats
listed there there would be some that
would be very relevant for the UK
there'd be others on that list that
would be much more likely to have
um to occur occur and other bits of the
world and I think uh sir Chris whitted's
statement sets out those diseases
um in part of his statement but the
question was how were they reflected in
the National risk assessment so they
would so the type of
um diseases which had a potential for
um International spread a public health
events of emergency concern as the who
calls it would be reflected in the
emerging infectious disease at risk that
went on a covid at SARS MERS
um scenario
finally was a Nerf tag asked to comment
on the blueprint at any any point by
either the 2017 or the 2018
who blueprint reports so those reports
were and the process was run by the
World Health Organization they brought
together an expert group to do so
um
I I think it was from individuals rather
than groups so I don't think nerve tag
themselves would have been asked but
that would have been up to the World
Health Organization
but from your perspective within your
department obviously there is there are
individuals such as we mentioned at the
beginning Professor Corby who's from a
member of nerve tag who is also part of
that prioritization committee for the
research and development blueprint so
following from that he's a member of
that committee he's a member of nerve
tag with nerve tag as a group themselves
be discussing the findings and the
observations of the report
with them nerve tap work themselves
thank you very much Miss Vincent thank
you Milady thank you that concludes the
questioning for Mrs Swinton and indeed
today's business
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much for your help Miss Winston
sorry again for the delay and we will
start again tomorrow at 10 o'clock thank
you my lady